cumulatively across everything I am
associated with we're in nine figures is
100 million plus I'm sure you guys are
very familiar with successful people
that hate their lives too it doesn't
always overlap where the more Jack you
are or the more successful you are
equals happy you could live a very
mediocre life and have a company that
has nine figures dude if you pull this
up you will find some
wild so Derek from more plates more
dates thank you so much for coming on
the iced coffee Hour podcast means a lot
no thanks for appr the way from Canada
too you're honored you were just in
Austin shooting your third ever podcast
with Joe Rogan how nervous are you
before going on Joe's podcast the first
time when you have no idea what to
expect it's pretty nerve-wracking
because you don't know how elaborate the
setup is if there's you know some sort
of scripted questions that they have
teed up for you like how it's going to
go and it's very very chill nonchalant
kind of just Bros talking and in the
studio it's literally kind of like this
it's just him and Jamie and nobody else
there's no one else that's so cool I
think that you know the more I don't
know lowkey you can do it the better
with Joe it's like obviously he's super
easy to speak with and I don't know like
we get along well so I would anytime he
wants to have me on like I'd love to be
on so that's amazing okay so I have a
question just on over optimizing because
I see a lot of people and they always
suggest things in like a very dogmatic
way like you need to optimize your
testosterone regulation your sleep your
nutrition your diet your medit
supplements hydration noap you have this
guy Brian Johnson that made an entire
career out of optimizing basically every
single thing that you can imagine for
longevity sake he says he's going to
live till he's like 150 or whatever his
does he concretely stay he says he says
he's like decreased aging by like 20
years or he was able to slow it down
considerably so it's like now when I
look at him obviously I I wonder the
validity of that statement but who am I
to say I'm not why you wonder though why
do I wonder like what is it about it
that makes you skeptical
like when I think of just a healthy
person I would say that is not the
profile that I generally imagine he just
looks really really pale I would say
Jack Jack you can't say that Jack it's
like the first thing that comes to mind
and here's the we're all thinking it
anyways uh is there a point in
optimizing too much yeah I think a lot
of the the the thing though is is a lot
of the lwh hanging fruit stuff when you
dump it into lifestyle diet training
sleep like you could easily
subcategorize it into just a few things
but then within that you get can get so
hypergranular where it's like infinite
amount of optimization possible so I
could say that yeah there are five
things that do 90 plus% and within that
that was just defining what is the
actual thing that defines a good
training regimen or a good sleep regimen
or whatever and he definitely takes it
to the you know absolute extreme that is
to the point point where you wouldn't
even be able to discern if what he is
doing in some capacities is more harmful
than helpful in my opinion because some
of the stuff he does is like
counterintuitive like he diets so
aggressively that it shuts down his
testosterone to some extent so now he
has exogenous testosterone he applies to
make up for the Lost hormones that he's
not producing because he's in literal
malnutrition state so like that's kind
of paradoxical and not really like is
that optimization at that point or you
just biohacking yourself to be Jack
while also depriving the yourself of
nutrients you know when you add in three
experimental drugs and then you're
already on 72 other things and then
you're also trying something new with
this like trying to determine what was
the thing that changed and how it
influenced its um cross interactions
with the other stuff you're already on
it's kind of hard to know for certain
like just the other day he was talking
about how he's adding oral minoxidil
into his regimen which is like a really
outdated anti-hypertensive medication
which is no longer used almost ever and
has a blackbox warning meaning it's like
the most prone to potentially lethal
side effects and it was repurposed as a
topical for hair loss when they found
out that when people were taking it they
were growing hair everywhere so they
these people were using this blood
pressure medication and just growing
body hair and hair on their head and
they were like huh if we repurpose this
for a topical and you put on your head
can you get the same effect turns out
you can with less side effects and you
keep it somewhat localized so some
people though to take it to the extreme
to get the maximum effect they will take
the old like really outdated oral
medication which is more effective but
also proportionally more side effect
ridden so is that just to keep the hair
on his head minoxidil a lot of the stuff
that he does to is not just about
objective like Health metrics it's also
about vanity I was wondering about like
being so low body fat is that healthy to
be in that St all the time he looks
great but is like is that optimal to
living to 150 yeah so that's that's the
thing too is what is the goal and are
you optimizing for that goal anyway
because a lot of what he does is not
necessarily in the extreme of longevity
it's also very intertwined with I want
to look good and be healthy
simultaneously which is fine but it's
like again some of these some of these
treatments are not necessarily like Pro
longevity like you try to argue that
oral minoxidil will help you live to 150
it's probably not so you know what maybe
he's able to get more attention looking
the way he does with the sixpack ABS
like look how healthy I am and then
indirectly it's like if you look good
and you look younger do you behave
younger and have some sort of like
health benefit that's a good point like
I'm sure I think there is literature on
that that does show that that is the
case if you look better you will
actually like be healthier yeah how much
of that do you think is just genetics in
terms of how long you're going to live
because it seems like there are these
communities in like Europe and Japan
where the people live into their early
hundreds and it seems pretty common and
maybe that could be diet uh or or you
know being stressfree or socializing
more but how much of that do you think
is genetic a lot of it so like there are
people you could find who have all of
the red flags of what you shouldn't do
and will still outlive you even if you
tried everything Brian Johnson does with
that said you can obviously have your
best shot at extending whatever it is
that you're working with you have a
certain hand of cards you're dealt and
and what you do with that is dependent
on all the factors that you impose upon
yourself lifestyle diet Etc and yeah I
would I think a lot of stuff could
extend lifespan fairly significantly
like when it comes to cardiovascular
disease it's like the number one uh
killer of people in the states right now
like even more so than cancer and that
is super preventable if you know what to
look for in blood work and know how to
get uh if you have a high quality doctor
overseeing your care some of the stuff
under that though like cancer and
whatnot like some of this stuff is so
nebulous to know if you're actually
going to be fine when you're going to
get it how you're going to get it how to
avoid it all you can do is kind of
optimize what you can and you know hope
it's impactful on uh number of years but
in general the thing that should be more
focused on I think is the quality of
life over quantity because there are
certain things you could do to extend
lifespan that aren't necessarily like
making life fun or worth living because
you could diet yourself into like a
state of metabolic nothing almost and be
like like for example a tiny old woman
might outlive a really jacked you know
big dude because she's you know like
doesn't really require that much to
sustain herself and has very little risk
factors from different aspects um I
don't know doesn't have a lot to impose
on her body demands wise her organs
don't need to support like way more
calories or what have you but is that
like a life you want to live where
you're depriving yourself of food
constantly doing these like three-day
fasts I'm not saying they don't have
validity it's just like you know it's
very speculative what this stuff does at
the end of the day and how much it
extends lifespan all you can really do
is things that we know work and are
worth doing like having a good diet
exercise sleep and I would say assessing
your hormones biomarkers Etc to make
sure stuff is at least as optimal as it
could be and then if you want to address
it further and go some degree in the
biohacking kind of optimization Realm by
manually intervening then you know
that's a judgment to make once you've
kind of like assessed things from an
educated angle so actionable things for
the viewer let's just say on average
it's a 18 to 35 year old man what five
or so things would you recommend that do
90% of the you get 90% of the results of
all optimization sleeping eight hours a
night and obviously you could get
granular around that and how you would
optimize that but let's just put the
bucket of like you know sleep make it
simple yeah yeah um assuming it's good
and then we have resistance training is
like very overlooked in terms of its
importance in my opinion like having
muscle and bone Integrity especially as
you get into older age is like of
critical
importance um I would say just basic
moving your body so getting 10,000 steps
a day I think it's a pretty like
concrete good cookie cutter
recommendation for most people um and I
like the idea of having like a goal that
you can actually know you reached and
feel good about you achieve something
rather than some nebulous just like move
around a lot because that's often what
you hear is move you know move your body
it's like okay well you know some people
need a step track or whatever to see
that they're actually hitting a number
that gives them that feedback I did good
today and I know that I kind of hit my
basis for what I need to be doing um so
I would say the resistance training
steps sleep from a diet perspective not
overeating the only way you would really
dictate if that's actually happening if
you're totally unaware of how to go
about tracking your macronutrients is
looking at the scale if you are eating
and it is going up on a regular basis
like you're eating too much and you need
to lower your portions and or look at
the quality of your food and kind of
determine is there you know am I eating
Ultra processed like calorie DSE hyper
palatable foods and maybe I should reel
back and assess what I'm eating why is
it that I'm overweight right now and
often like you can't outtrain a bad diet
or if you do it's very difficult to and
most won't very rare circumstances do I
find people who are training so much
that they could eat whatever it exists
but they're outliers in general people
need to just look at what they're eating
and probably at least for a month or two
meticulously track like every calorie
that enters their mouth and if you're
not gaining weight on average on a
weekly basis then you know you're either
at maintenance calories or if you're
losing weight you're in a deficit and as
long as you are at a healthy body
composition you're not gaining weight
unless your goal is to gain muscle then
you know I think calorie energy balance
in general is kind of like the fourth
bucket I would say fifth is like getting
Diagnostics to actually assess that what
you're doing is moving you in the right
direction too because there are certain
genetic predispositions that no matter
what you do lifestyle diet Etc you might
be overlooking some significant uh
problem that exists within your um
ancestral you know like your parents
grandparents whatever that is passed on
to you that goes overlooked that you
might want to you know get diagnostic
oversight in order to make sure not only
that the things you're doing on a
regular basis are providing actionable
feedback that your you know levels on
all metrics are getting better and
looking optimal for sustaining health
and quality of life but also that you
don't have some weird outlying genetic
predisposition that you're totally
unaware of that would have killed you in
15 years well I guess since we're on the
topic of longevity did you know that 50%
of businesses fail in the first 5 years
well thanks to today's sponsor Shopify
you'll have all of the tools to ensure
that longevity is the only option for
those una aware Shopify is the global
e-commerce platform that's already
transformed millions of businesses
worldwide for example Shopify is has an
endless list of Integrations third-party
apps and flexible templates to customize
your online store exactly the way you
want it and what's that Shopify apart
from their competitors is their ability
to turn browsers into buyers with the
internet's best converting checkout
that's 36% better than leading
e-commerce platforms and fun fact
Shopify actually Powers 10% of all
e-commerce in the United States
supporting Brands like Alberts rothy and
Brooklyn and in over 175 countries in
fact my coffee company bankroll
coffee.com which you can go there right
now to check it out and see for them but
you can see what Shopify is doing we've
used Shopify for the last 3 years and we
used them because they were the best by
far and they've been fantastic plus they
have an award-winning support team to be
able to help you any step of the way so
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com
that's shopify.com to grow your business
no matter what stage you're in
shopify.com all lower case for a $1
month trial period thank you so much
Shopify and back to the episode does it
matter what you eat as long as the C
calories add up to a certain amount like
eating 1500 calories worth of Oreos
versus you know 1500 calories of steak
does it matter if the calories are the
same for sure yeah like the quality of
food at the end of the day if you're in
a deficit and eating less than your
expending from a caloric standpoint you
will lose weight but the proportion of
weight lost will be suboptimal if you're
eating just Oreos to achieve that so if
you're even if you're training perfectly
you're doing your cardio you're eating
1,500 calories of just McDonald's versus
is high quality red meat complex carbs
like whatever the difference in your
body composition at the end of it will
be pretty significant in that you will
have more muscle you will have better
health markers you'll feel better like
there's a clear difference in terms of
the outcome although you could still buy
like scientifically you will lose weight
it's just impossible to not if you're in
a deficit of energy but a lot of systems
in your body will be performing worse if
you are eating the you know got it and
how do you optimize your sleep I've seen
some people say that you're supposed to
do everything completely blacked out or
you're supposed to have a light next to
you that slowly wakes you up I found
that for myself I do best with natural
sunlight in the morning like despite
what everyone says I like seeing the
sound come up and I find that I sleep
better waking up somewhat naturally what
time do you wake up though I would say
about 8 uh maybe 7 the earliest and the
Sun is up at what time here I would say
5:30 6 give or take so I guess it
depends on how your sleep tracks with
the sun cuz it's like let's just say
you're trying to wake up 4 hours after
it comes up having that light entering
your room and disrupting your sleep
might not be ideal versus if you're
actually waking up with it I would say
that's pretty optimal if you could go to
sleep as it's you know when it's dark
and then waking up with it you're pretty
much replicating what is an ideal
circadian rhythm a lot of people don't
have the luxury of that they work shift
work like whatever it is in which case
you have to get a little bit more uh I
don't know granular and what what you're
doing and yeah I think blackout blinds
are great um depending on the person cuz
it's also pretty hard to get up when
it's blacked out in the room too and
that's where like the natural light can
be helpful yeah I like I would love and
it's obviously unreasonable to ever
suggest this to anyone but having a
device that would blackout blinds that
open slowly at like a certain time of
day like based on when the sun is coming
up or you know when you actually want to
wake up cuz even right now a lot of
people if you have a black out room me
included I have to still have certain
tactics sometimes to make sure I don't
just lie there cuz when you wake up know
if you don't have that natural light
queuing you to be getting does that not
exist something that just opens the
shades get an automatic electronic
something where you just push a button
that's that's highly you want to you
want it to adjust every day though based
on the sun like the a lot of people
would argue just go to bed on time but
it's like it's not realistic for
everyone obviously right it's insane
that I'm saying this cuz it sounds so
lazy but I'll just be honest honest I
was thinking about buying some wood or a
super long extendable stick cuz my
blinds are probably 9 feet away from my
bed where as soon as I wake up I just
you know and I just like open it up a
little bit cuz getting out of the bed
when it is Pitch Black in your room even
if it's 9:00 a.m. it's just harder yeah
that's the opposite of lazy that's like
intuitive [__] right there but yeah
getting to bed I think the timing of it
is very important so your body adapt to
cues especially when you're eating or
exposure to sunlight so if you go to bed
at 10: every day trying to go to bed at
the same time every day and trying to
wake up around the same time every day
and ingraining this rhythm in your brain
is like one of the most important things
um I would say avoiding eating as close
to bed as possible ideally would be
worthwhile as well so some people they
will eat you know midnight you know a
late night snack or whatever or have a
lot of their calories right before
sleeping and your metabolism will be
trying to essentially use up that food
when you were in bed and trying to fall
asleep and when you're trying to fall
asleep to get into sleep you need to
lower your body temperature a certain
amount and if you are ingesting a bunch
of calories and requiring your body to
then like fire up metabolic processes to
actually use it up like that's a heat
generating process so you are actually
impeding your ability to fall asleep
when you e but then why is late night
eating so popular willpower is
diminished
and it's like access it does feel really
good to eat a big meal and then just go
to bed afterwards depending it's hard
for me to sleep when I eat before bed
yeah I I actually cut off myat I've just
noticed it as a pattern in my life it's
extremely hard to fall asleep like
there's definitely a individual
component to it because like for example
I wouldn't suggest going to bed super
hungry either because then maybe you're
too hungry to get you know stay asleep
some people are different and that's
where you kind of have to play around
with it I'm not suggesting that everyone
should do this but in general if you are
eating the majority of your calories too
close to bed it will be harder to get
into deep sleep and stay asleep so I
would just be mindful of that a lot of
people I know try to stop eating like at
least two to three hours out I want to
get onto the story and how you acquired
all of this knowledge and then how you
leveraged this knowledge to build $1 100
million plus business which you've
talked about on other podcasts as well
but before we get into that there's one
other random question that I have to ask
which is Andrew Tate says oh if you're
depressed you get a sixpack and then
come back to me and tell me if you're
still depressed we've talked about
optimizing all these different facets of
your life what are the actual results of
optimizing these things aside from just
vanity does it actually make a
significant impact on your quality of
life and internal metrics yeah like
being lean is
unquestionably good for health obviously
that can be taken to the extreme with
guys like Brian Johnson who calorie
deprive themselves so aggressively that
they then need to use exogenous hormones
to maintain decent function um and a lot
of bodybuilders do that too self-
admittedly they'll get shredded and use
exogenous steroids in order to maintain
like high quality life you know uh
strength in the gym muscle tissue to not
have it deteriorate as they diet down
and they'll be at you know like single
digit body fat percentage and be
shredded walking around and still
functioning well because they're
literally shooting the hormones into
themselves so when you're doing it
naturally though like there is a
goldilock Zone whereby if you're too fat
like it's not conducive to Optimal
Health and if you're too lean it's also
not conducive to Optimal Health and
having a good happy medium is
like uh unquestionably good in all
metrics of Health essentially and mental
health as well yeah yeah for sure
especially like the impact has on brain
fog too eating the diet that is
conducive to like a lean body
composition and you being metabolically
flexible and using energy efficiently
for actual recovery of tissue that is
metabolically active rather than just
like having your blood sugar stay
elevated and then you're sitting in your
chair and not actually using it up for
anything um you know you get into these
roller coasters of brain fog and a lot
of people who are more metabolically fit
don't experience that how did you learn
all of this how do you get into this um
probably the same way anyone in their
Niche gets really deep so like in your
Niche it just you know you get
enthralled in it because it interests
you to no end so just will sit there and
in just assimilate information all day
even if you weren't making content about
it you probably were interested in it to
begin with and that's kind of like I
think where the best content creators
come from are people who would have done
it anyways uh I'm not suggesting that
you need to do that necessarily but like
for me you know from being a teenager
I've been ingesting information from
wherever I can to try and get as
knowledgeable as I can about anything
that interests me and I'm just the type
of person that will sit there on the
computer and just bury myself in papers
and asking people anything I need to to
learn what I can and um just always
information seeking I just really I
don't know mentally get rewarded from
learning stuff I care about do you know
why you're so interested in this
specific
field um I think because it affects like
broadspectrum performance it's not just
performance in the gym or in sports it's
also mentally and it help it's super
overlapping with entrepreneurial
Endeavors as well so having a mentally
dialed cognitive state is obviously
incredibly conducive to high quality
work um business Acumen performance in
your businesses Etc like it all is
overlapping and not just about health
but also about performance trying to
optimize all angles of that in order to
not only Stave off disease maximize my
performance but also be able to impart
that information to friends and family
who otherwise are like blindly going
through the medical system something
that is what I'm passionate about and
kind of led me down the tele medicine
route because in Canada especially
you're kind of just told to um go home
if you ask for anything and you're not
like literally dying in front of them so
what I find really interesting is I have
a lot of friends that like have gone
through medical school I have I've met
quite a few different doctors and stuff
like that and I like to ask what they
teach them in medical school and a lot
of the times it's not natural and
organic things that will fix these
issues that I feel like intuitively
could be fixed like a lot of mental
illnesses is fixed by fixed by giving
like administering pills and medication
and stuff like that where I feel like if
we tried some more like organic routes
first you'd probably yield better or at
least more like foundational results
perhaps a lot of I think depression is
the one that's that's brought up a lot
perhaps there's a for for some people
it's an underlying condition of you know
uh in the brain but for others it could
be their environmental conditions or
their situation that's really
contributing to that so fixing whatever
that issue is could solve their you know
depression versus medication oh for sure
like I know some of the most successful
PE I'm sure you guys are very familiar
with successful people that hate their
lives too it doesn't always overlap
where you know the more Jack you are or
the more successful you are equals happy
and often times there's like a honic
treadmill where these people get happy
and then they realize that wasn't what
made them happy and they have this
internal crisis about what actually is
the meaning of life and then they get
sent down this rabbit hole and they're
less happy than somebody who's you know
just living a average life objectively
so um yeah like a lot of this stuff can
be fixed naturally if they are a general
practitioner they may only get a certain
amount of time with exposure to
knowledge about hormones or to what have
you um and that could be to the
detriment of being the person you want
to defer to when you're trying to learn
about a specific subsystem of the body
so if I want to learn about how hormones
work or um you know like uh reproductive
health or testosterone like I don't
necessarily want to talk to my family
doc I might want to talk to an
endocrinologist and that's why there
Specialties where they lean into things
heavier um but even then often times you
are subject to whatever the current
curriculum literature says which might
be outdated for all we know so and often
times you'll see um yeah people going to
multiple Specialists and getting told
things that even as a just person who
consumes YouTube on a regular basis you
might be like that sounds wrong I've
heard you know totally contradictory
advice from multiple people now I'm not
saying use YouTube for your advice over
an endocrinologist obviously but there's
certainly some element of uh not every
doctor knows everything and there are
amazing doctors that do great things but
just because you're credential that
doesn't equal you know the most
knowledgeable always so and yeah a lot
of stuff can be fixed naturally but you
know what before we go into that we have
some really exciting news that we're now
filming our episodes in 4k this one is
not in 4k but the future episodes are
all in 4k the downside though is that
it's very expensive to do we need a lot
of special equipment but what's most
remarkable is that we were able to grow
to almost 900,000 subscribers without
ever doing 4K you don't need crazy
equipment if you want to grow on YouTube
and our sponsor streamyard is there to
help streamyard is a recording and live
streaming software that allows you to
create high quality content with just
the click of a button all you need is a
camera and an internet connection and
you'll be able to stream right from your
computer across multiple social media
platforms at the same time like YouTube
Instagram Facebook LinkedIn and that
feature in and of itself makes
streamyard extremely worth it because
what do you always say about being on
every platform you're leaving money on
the table if you're not doing it mhm
that's what I say right MH okay anyways
guys if you want to be on every single
platform which is super important you
want to create high quality content with
just the click of a button for free they
offer a free package package with the
link down below it would mean so much to
us stream also supported us all the way
through 2023 and they're supporting us
all the way through 2024 so it would
means so much if you guys just click
that link Down Below in the description
try it out streamyard it's definitely
worth it thank you so much streamyard
and back to the episode when did you
start working out um probably when I was
17ish I was the last person in my friend
group to start and I played basketball I
was like a skinny runt who didn't really
care about working out at all yeah just
what was the point it didn't really help
me shoot three-pointers so didn't really
care and then my friends just got really
into it and peer pressured me into it
essentially because it kind of got
stupid being there and hanging out with
them when they're you know bench
pressing and whatever and I'm just
standing there doing nothing so so I
might as well join then I made some
progress relatively quickly and then I
like damn like this is cool I'm actually
seeing visual changes happening and then
kind of it's called getting the iron bug
you get bit by it yeah yeah yeah so I
kind of got bit by the iron bug and then
um it definitely superseded my uh I
don't know interest in basketball to
where I just kind of leaned into that
and then continued thereafter was there
a correlation with gaining muscle and
attention from women or was it your
confidence that was affected by that
that actually caused better or more
attention from woman the confidence
component is definitely a huge variable
that most people Overlook and actually I
would say that for the first few years
it was probably worse because I did a
lot of like dirty bulking I'm sure you
guys have heard of dirty bulking yeah so
you just eat anything because you think
that gaining weight equals good even at
the expense of literally becoming fat so
I gain like 60 PBS I think 60 pound how
long I think my first three months I
gained 40 to 50 that that's a lot how is
that even possible it's possible trust
me you were eating like8 9,000 car yeah
well no I was just the thing is a lot of
people don't actually count and when you
start counting to the calorie
you know a lot of times you realize you
weren't ingesting as much as you thought
or the opposite for certain Obe people
that over estimate or whatever so or
underestimate so for me I was counting
meticulously and also slamming like
Weight Gainer shakes and eating really
garbage food like anything I could do
even to the extent that if I threw up I
would be like oh [__] I got to go eat
again to make up for that yeah it got
intense so that wasn't normal but that
was like so how did you dial back after
that well eventually enough people tell
you that are close to you and care about
you that you're getting fat and you
should probably tone a back of it and
you know the response at the time it's
like you don't understand dirty bulking
this is how you do it so they're just
telling you you're f it came probably
after the first year is I did like a
little bit of a diet down I think I
bulked up again thereafter and then I
dieted again it took probably like two
or three cycles of bulking and cutting
with the the next bulk not being as
aggressive as the first before I kind of
actually got to a body composition that
looked like okay you're actually a guy
who goes to the gym and works out so
after that point though I had enough
muscle where even when I bulked up a bit
I was a lot more cognizant about how far
I would take it and also you have enough
muscle tissue underneath that you don't
look as fat because you actually have
the muscle in conjunction with the fat
that you've gained to kind of like there
a lot of people with six packs that are
bodybuilders that are still holding
quite a bit of body fat but they have so
much muscle that kind of like they still
look vascular so at what point though
did that help you with women um a few
years in uh I probably didn't even talk
to women for the first two years I was
in the gym too so I don't even know if
you could count it as a fair comparison
but after I got lean actually lean for
the first time I started to kind of go
to my comfort zone more and had the
confidence to go up to chicks and talk
to them and strike up conversations in
my University walking around and I could
have there was definitely times though
where I had as good or more success when
when I was objectively like perhaps a
bit overweight too so a lot of it is
just how you're speaking how confident
you are how your interaction goes if
there's chemistry stuff like that so
some people definitely over optimize to
the degree that they will not even talk
to the opposite section unless they're
like cutting so I don't suggest that
because I've heard about that like they
they they don't take off their shirt
until they're like lean yeah post cut is
that just motivation to well you
definitely get body dysmorphia once to
get into this Fitness industry
especially where you think that if you
don't have a six-pack equals I'm very
fat and my is that just because you're
around people and everyone has a
six-pack so if you don't have one then
you feel like it's not even that you're
around them physically it's that you're
looking at them on social media and this
is the norm of expectation in Fitness
like right now I'm actually relatively
untrained I kind of like changed my
priorities a bit in the past couple
years to where I am in the gym far less
far less than I want to be and I think
it's optimal but it was just at the
expense of a lot of business stuff that
was taking off that I just at least at
the time unjustifiably Justified it was
worth not going to the gym as much which
I'm trying to change this next year but
like in that um domain it's kind of like
when you get into the fitness industry
you kind of get this assumption that
everyone I don't know has uh you have
this perception of what is considered
good and is like very very skewed to
where me now compared to a few years ago
people be like you have a dad bod or you
look out of shape it looks like you
don't train anymore it's like to a
Layman objectively that's an insane
statement but to like a fitness industry
guy that actually might be a reasonable
answer it's like Derek you look like you
don't even [__] train anymore well
that's the thing it's like if I go on
YouTube uh uh shorts or Instagram reals
or Tik Tok and stuff like that the only
stuff that gets views and does well are
people that are just absolutely shredded
sort of sort of you disagree yeah like I
don't even take my shirt off really for
videos I don't even do training footage
anymore I used to back in the day but
lately I'm just like a talking head in
videos in front of a wall but what I'm
saying like maybe it's just my algorithm
but like if the video genre is Fitness
it's usually someone with an insane
shredded body yeah but you also some of
the most respected and successful people
in the industry are individuals that
don't fit the norm of the genetic enom
cuz there you'd be surprised like some
people like Sam suck for example yeah
he's an outlier and obviously he's like
SAU to hell but it's uh it not every guy
who's that there are plenty of people
way more jacked than him that don't get
any attention and they post videos
regularly like there's just a certain
element that some people are very
likable and post content that a lot of
people relate to Andor just like the
person to some you know significantly
greater extent but there are plenty of
body builders that are the most hyp
extreme example of Jack shredded
whatever who have objectively low
followings and then some that are on the
Other Extreme like Chris bum said is
like the most popular fitness person
ever probably at least by proportional
metrics obviously like Arnold back in
the day was huge but I mean like sheer
engagement wise now he beats like aess
celebrities so and like obviously you
could argue okay well he's the best
physique and that reinforces what I said
but it's like there are guys that will
have don't even post their physique that
are in the industry that still do very
very well too and have how is Sam so big
he looks like a cloud he's big oh like
big I thought you were asking like
popularity wise I was like what what do
you cloud and his YouTube channel like
how's it okay no but he's a a massive
guy H yeah genetics
steroids adhering to his diet uh
meticulously and hitting his calorie and
protein goals like the guy's life is
essenti revolved around going to the gym
and eating his meals and his content is
entirely essentially dictated by
following him do those things so when
it's your job to adhere to it like I
would say it's a bit more likely that
you will and then in addition to that
he's also a genetic Phenom in that he
hyper responds to what he's doing in
terms of hormones is he is he open about
his steroid use I don't think he's ever
said anything about it I don't think so
but say based on your knowledge you
think oh 1 million perc I would
bet like my net worth on it so with uh
how could you tell well you just said he
looks like a CL I know but like but you
objectively you you have this this
Vision that you could say this person is
on steroids yeah what do you see that a
normal person wouldn't I don't know how
his brother trains but like first of all
there's a pretty clear distinction
between him and somebody who has very
similar Gene gentics and they both train
and one looks like a amateur level or
almost I don't know some people would
argue that he's like borderline low
level Pro bodybuilder within a couple
years and his brother looks like a
normal guy still maybe his brother just
started and this is an unfair comparison
but at the end of the day the
progression he's made from what looked
like a decent natural physique was so
rapid that it would be unexplainable to
gain that much tissue naturally it's
just physically impossible so having
gone to the gym for a certain amount of
time and then to explode and gain 50
pounds of muscle thereafter it's just
not a physiologic thing that could occur
yeah I couldn't that's probably the best
explanation obviously you could look at
them and objectively say this physique
is not natural because it is x amount of
pounds higher than what most Naturals
can achieve who are at the highest level
of you know tested sport or whatever
like there's a lot of metrics you could
look to but also it's just easy to see
his progress is unnatural do you think
Sam has a responsibility to be open
about about his steroid usage with his
platform not really I don't know like
the guy I think just by existing will
encourage hormone use unfortunately and
then some people will criticize him for
that probably unfairly so because he's
just a guy who makes content and wants
to do what he does and maybe he competes
one day maybe he doesn't but it's like I
don't think just because you're
influential and look great and take [__]
equals you need to like tell everyone
everything I think you have a duty to
not lie to their faces about it probably
but or to monetize in a way that is
leveraging your like fake natural status
in order to get rich off of products
that are you know promising things that
are just untrue but above and beyond
that like I don't necessarily think he
has to sit down and make a video and say
yep as you guys probably guessed I'm a
natural and like here's why you
shouldn't do it and blah blah blah so
it's like people got to kind of make
their own decisions and take some
responsibility and I'm sure he did the
same thing when he sat down there was
one day where Sam Su like sat down at as
a natural and looked at probably YouTube
videos dug into some whatever research
may be asked some friends like is it
worth it if I do this like what am I
trying to get out of it he had that
assessment too and he was probably
inspired by someone else and should that
guy have not been on social media being
jacked and sick looking I don't know you
know did that guy have a responsibility
to tell Sam he would have died if he
took gear or something I don't know
that's kind of a you know speculative
thing so let's talk a little bit about
your businesses you have your clinic and
you have your business I think it's the
supplement business does like $100
million or so a year at least my my
first million they guessed didn't
disagree 6 to8 million a month and you
agreed cumulatively across everything I
am associated with we're in what is nine
figures is 100 million plus right so
that's territory but I'm not going to
get like hypers specific on which
businesses do what and whatever how do
you decide to turn this into a
business um which one the like my
channel even or what do you mean I guess
everything even the supplements the your
channel like how do you decide to
monetize your interest in Fitness by the
way the thing I should preface which I
see a lot of people don't do is when you
say 100 million no one talks about net
numbers and like let's not like a lot of
times I see uh maybe business owners who
are incentivized to actually show how
well they're doing because they're part
of some entrepreneurial like upsell
thing like these numbers are not
necessarily like the owner equals like
this you don't keep this money like a
lot of it's reinvested to build the
businesses and if you're you said 50 to
100 employees as well per company yeah
like I'm trying to I just want to add a
preface because a lot of people see
these big numbers especially as
headlines and they will very much take
and run with that some unrealistic
expectation of how business works and
even if this is a goal you are
considering pursuing like understand
that just these numbers don't mean your
take-home is some like like you could
live a very mediocre life and have like
a company that is nine figures if
depending on what your goal is with it
so just putting that out there um but
anyways the way transitioning into this
was um a lot about my content and what I
would promote or give education about to
begin with so when I started making
content
about uh nutrition supplementation
pharmacology hormone optimization like
it was very very Centric around these
things to begin with and often times
reviewing other companies that are you
know at the Cutting Edge or doing things
that I think are bad or good and giving
my opinions um often times I would have
affiliate relationships too where I
would have here you know use my
affiliate code to get you know Kickback
a commission support the channel and
using this product that I think is the
best of this specific industry and after
a while once you build up enough funds
I'm sure similar to you you made some
YouTube ad Revenue you've made some
affiliate commissions you've had some
sponsorships and it's like okay well do
I want to build equity for this other
company now or do I want to go like
pivot into my own thing and is the B
with allocation of time worthwhile to
actually lean into it or am I just
taking away from my bread and butter and
making that kind of calculation for me
at least on my three main businesses
which is Gorilla mind mer tele medicine
and intelligence shop those three things
in particular I feel like I have enough
of a expertise in and care enough about
personally to lean into as worth my time
allocation so like in particular the
gorilla mind company is dietary
supplements typically oriented around
sports performance
and energy drinks more recently New
Tropics cognitive enhancement that's
kind of like the main products we offer
and then mer health is the tele medicine
diagnostic side of things not a
traditional trt Clinic a lot of people
title these clinics as trt clinics and
justifiably so for many of them but we
pride ourselves in being like diagnostic
oversight and optimizing Health before
looking at any of these other things so
that's worth mentioning because I think
it's often these companies get lumped
into this kind of like narrow kind of
like bit more sketchy territory but is a
preventative medicine platform and then
third is intelligent shop which is like
men's hair loss prevention in particular
and the pharmacology around that is
something I've made tons of content on
and it's something I found very very
interesting so making products that
actually work centered around that and
then also something a lot of people
don't know is I used to make fragrance
reviews I am just like a fragrance
connoisseur so I would get girls to rate
fragrances go to University campus girls
to rate fragrances yeah if you look at
some of my old videos I would walk
around University campuses and be like
what do you think of this one compared
to this one R it out of 10 which one's
more sexy etc etc do you put like one on
one armpit and the other one on the
other no I spray test strips oh
okay what are you doing I'm just scar
how do you get like a girl to AB test it
you know test strips yeah so they it
would be like a blind test CU they don't
see the bottle and it's just on a strip
and they would give their opinion and
then these like fragrance battles
get endless views like there's no time
where as somebody who's into fragrances
you will not get views by getting
attractive women to rates even
fragrances that have existed for decades
I don't know why it's just like even me
I like watch I want to go back I'm weird
I like the smell of gasoline and
cigarettes I don't know why so you would
love Fahrenheit by Dior it is a very
polarizing fragrance that only somebody
who actually likes what you just said so
Random Sharpies as well Sharpies I love
Sharpies yeah what the smell when you
start up a car like that weird sort of
like I don't know it's a smell like I
like that yeah dude especially if you're
like uh if you can pull it off cuz again
there's a certain scent that needs to be
congruent with like you as a person to
really not just come across as why do
you smell like a diesel engine or
something but like if you can pull it
off it's a pretty sick scent but um
anyway so you should check that out but
for me I made all these reviews and I
always thought you know it'd be sick if
one day I had my own fragrances so this
intelligent shop company is kind of like
a miscellaneous self-care company but
it's hair loss and hair loss prevention
oriented products it also has skin care
and then fragrances that I develop and I
think we're launching our seventh
fragrance this month so what are some of
the Crown winners of the fragrance AB
test that you did on college campuses o
um from existing Brands things that I
could recommend um Spice Bomb is a
really good one by Victor and Ralf for
winter and fall that one consistently
won well why just for winter and fall
certain fragrance have certain notes
that are more conducive to be appealing
in warmer or colder weather and some
actually stink almost when you're having
it in the wrong setting or might be
might be overwhelming for example if you
had like a really boozy sexy smelling
fragrance in a date setting would be
nice but in the office would be quite
off-putting so having something oriented
for what you're doing or if you're in
the gym you wouldn't wear like diesel
engine fragrance you know people like
what the hell is this guy doing so like
there you would want to smell like you
just came out of the shower at most if
anything so like stuff like that and
having contextual situations that are
conducive to like okay this one's for
this this one's for this that's kind of
like what we did and um yeah some of the
best ones off the top of my head a
really good cost effective one I would
say if people are looking for a summer
fragrance that's pretty guaranteed to be
a hit with women is Nautica Voyage I
think it's the bestselling fragrance on
Amazon it's like 17 bucks for 100
milliliters and it's quite it's quite
good A lot of people have it so it's
common but it's reliable on a budget for
sure ior Savage Savage Savage I feel
like I've heard you know Jeremy
fragrance dude that guy is a character
that's like I think that's like his
favorite by the way he's probably the
first one he's not maybe he's not the
first but he's one of the first people
that inspired like the whole fragrance
battle thing so some of his old videos
are not as much as newer videos but his
older ones are like really entertaining
well done I wish he would go back to
that style but he's uh been consumed by
the Tik Tok dopamine
circuitry unfortunately but for that one
Sage is like one of the most widely
appreciated fragrances but to the
detriment that it's not unique
whatsoever so you will almost certainly
smell like some chick's ex-boyfriend if
you wear it I want to talk about
supplements cuz we had Dr Mike on the
podcast and he said the supplement
industry is ripe with scams basically
like a lot of supplements are not
regulated and you could kind of just
like package anything into anything and
then sell it as anything yeah I think a
lot of the claims could not be tested
and because they're supplements or
they're all natural uh there's very
little regulation with that so people
are trying to Pedal anything because
there's such high margins on supplements
what supplements do you think are
actually valid and like like multiv
vitamins for example I feel like
everyone takes multivitamins is that
something that people should be
incorporating into their diet and what
supplements should people be wary of it
very much depends on your individual
situation but I want to try and be as
general as possible because I could say
for a multi your diet could cover your
bases for all I know a lot of people
don't need it but it's good insurance
kind of it's almost like an insurance
policy type supplement which I think is
worthwhile for a lot of people but you
don't necessarily need it for Optimal
Health fortunately a lot of the vitamins
in it won't actually kind of like
accumulate you'll just urinate out the
excess and you kind of know at least
you're topping up what you needed and
then the rest would kind of not stick
around and cause harm as much but a lot
of people are deficient in vitamin D
let's like pretty damn common nowadays
so I think that's a pretty impactful one
how do you know if you're deficient in
vitamin D okay so you would check your
vitamin D in a blood test and it would
show you are either it's shocking how
are there symptoms to that though or
would you just not know low testosterone
is one of them um mood emotional
stability even ability to build muscle
in some Capac like a lot of stuff is
impacted by vitamin D it's actually a
hormone technically like it's a steroid
hormone even though it's called a
vitamin yeah so it's pretty impactful on
hormone systems in the body and being
deficient in it it's like one of the few
things that not not one of the few
things but one of the most impactful
things that if you're deficient it will
markedly decrease your testosterone
levels and also your response to that
testosterone as well so people do notice
a big difference we had Ty Lopez on the
podcast and he has a vitamin D tracker
based on the sun and like where he is on
the world so he could go outside and say
here I only need 10 minutes but over
there I need an hour in the sun to get
that vitamin D that sounds super fishy
like almost more fishy than the age
so I yeah I don't know who it does it
matter if you're getting Vitamin D from
the Sun or like a supplement or is
vitamin D vitamin D like I would say in
general things you can get naturally are
better and they go through an actual
regulating framework when you're taking
stuff naturally like for example in
Foods it'll have like co-actors and
different things that support absorption
or what have you that may be in a
supplement getting like a mega do in one
shot might not be the optimal way to do
it when it comes to Vitamin D it kind of
it's tough because often times the way
you ended up deficient to begin with is
because your environment is not
conducive to a good vitamin D level
unless you are intentionally depriving
yourself of sunlight at which point it's
kind of like just get outside more and
then if you're still deficient like I
don't know like it's also an efficiency
thing too do I want to sit outside for
how long versus you know like for me I
think a lot of people would benefit from
a supplement but I also think if you can
get it naturally like it's probably a
superior although I couldn't point to
any literature that shows like an AB
test of it um so yeah that's a super
impactful one um some other things
magnesium a lot of people are super
deficient in magnesium and that's super
impactful on testosterone levels too
among other things zinc impactful on
testosterone a lot of people are
deficient especially people who are
avoiding red meat purposefully I think
beef liver is actually great as like
ironic that the liver King is like gets
a lot of scrutiny one of the things he
did say that is worthwhile I think is
liver on a regular basis it's like one
of the most Coline D vitamin A dents um
nutrient wrench Foods in general it's
like Nature's multivitamin is what they
call it and I think that product despite
tasting horrendous if you can stomach it
you only need an ounce every couple days
even to hit a lot of your micronutrient
needs and if you think it tastes bad you
could actually take a desiccated like
beef liver supplement that could be
potentially impactful so I think that's
you know interesting to look at for sure
um in general I would say magnesium um
vitamin D are two that I see very
prominently problematic that will
actually notably impact perceived
quality of life sleep hormone production
among a myriad of other things so we can
go down the rabbit hole as much as you
want but that's like off the top my head
a couple things how much liver do you
eat an ounce a day unless I'm traveling
or I just don't want to eat it which is
relatively frequent so sometimes I I'll
use a supplement myself sometimes so
you're traveling right now you're just
in Austin now you're here in Vegas
you're here for like a week and a half
you said yep how are you getting liver
while you're here yeah I just take six
capsules a day I'm good oh you take
capsules yeah yeah okay got it okay so
yeah I don't love the taste of it but I
try to eat it when I can and what about
vegetarianism one of my very close
friends is a vegetarian he has been for
like probably five years at this point
would you say that that's a diet that
you have to be extremely cautious if
you're subscribing to to like making
sure that you're getting every available
nutrient do you think that objectively
you're probably healthier if you're
eating Animal product I think think that
you will undoubtedly need to supplement
with a few more things than the normal
person to hit your nutrient needs for
sure bioavailable B vitamins having high
quality protein cuz even if you get a
gram of protein on a nutrition label for
certain like vegetarian based products
is not necessarily the same equivalent
impact on protein synthesis rates as
like uh meat derived red meat derived so
um you need to be a bit more
knowledgeable I would say I don't think
it's impossible to thrive on a
vegetarian Di diet I just think you need
to be a bit more mindful of intake of
certain things like where you getting
your creatine from where you getting
your carnitine from or you getting your
bioavailable B vitamins and sometimes
supplementation is warranted to actually
be able to adhere to the diet and still
get the upside of these uh vitamins and
minerals and whatnot like Brian Johnson
like good luck getting all your stuff
without supplements are there any
ingredients that people should outright
avoid like Ultra processed stuff in
general is typically going to be you
know stripped of nutrients and or not
that as helpful as the caloric
equivalent could be of something that is
like I don't know natural quote unquote
so often times I try to get my you know
micronutrients from food when I can like
actually eating liver versus taking it
in a supplement but it kind of depends
on your workload too like exercise wise
I could say you know don't eat as much
sugar because you're sedentary for
example I don't know how much sugar you
need to actually support your uh demands
so it's like if you are somebody who's
hardly going to the gym or you're work
workouts are very very minimally
intensive and don't require that much
carbohydrate to support them maybe you
can get away with less and you're just
unnecessarily pounding sugar versus some
other guy might literally need to have
like shakes around their workout that
are filled with you know sugar to help
support it and that's like the hyp
extreme bodybuilder but it depends on
the person um I'm sure there are a lot
of things that I am just not thinking of
though that are really obvious loow
hanging fruit things to avoid sure what
are your thoughts on fasting I think
that it is helpful
for um sustainability of caloric
adherence for a lot of people even for
me personally like I will wake up and
try to not eat for as close to Six to 8
hours as possible typically depending on
what I'm doing if I'm going to the gym
that day maybe it differs but in general
that approach for me has resulted in
ability to eat the majority of my food
later in the day not so close to bed
that it impacts my sleep cuz again
you're back loging your calories that
could be problematic too if you wait
until right before bed but for me I am
most mentally clear when I'm not eating
so if I could just work through hunger
and use like minor tactics to kind of
push my way through um whether that's
coffee you know uh chewing gum sometimes
you know energy drink here and there
yeah I find the same thing in the
morning if I don't eat and I just have
coffee I find myself being a lot sharper
I could think quicker as soon as I eat
for whatever reason even if it's small
something I slow down even 10% but still
that adds up over the course of a year
yeah so I've always just I think I think
the validity of it is uh it's certainly
there for entrepreneurs who want to
maintain as sharp of a window of work as
possible um when it comes to actual diet
outcomes some people really benefit from
it because when they try and split their
meals out equally over oh I'm going to
try the traditional four or five or even
six meals a day of equal split
everything they aren't able to feel
satisfied off small portions but then
some people like when you look to
literature you'll often find that it
doesn't play out for the population that
they're
assessing relative to what another guy
might find his best for them so you
almost need to experiment a bit and
fortunately with diet it's not like
you're experimenting with a drug
necessarily that might screw you up like
if you try fasting intermittent fasting
for a couple weeks and you don't like it
you know like you tried it and it wasn't
a big deal you can go back to trying
something else or going back to what
worked for you the best before so I
think it's worth everyone kind of
experimenting but I've definitely seen
some super impactful um situations where
people went from a traditional I need to
eat right when I wake up to stretching
their eating windows and then getting
more work done being more productive
also being able to eat less overall per
day because they feel like a big meal is
harder to overeat on than like little
small tiny portions so it depends on the
person though for sure and it's not
necessarily the most ideal for building
muscle having all your protein like
shoved into one or two meals got it
what's your recommendation for hair
loss um it depends what stage you're at
and how aggressive you want to be
because at the end of the day
unfortunately there is uh not really
anything that exists that's super
impactful that isn't manipulating
hormone systems so when it comes to hair
loss prevention the best thing you can
do is get in front of it before it's
like C medically perceivable so for me
it was not just accelerated by uh
anabolic steroids when I was younger but
in addition to that once you actually
visually see it in the mirror like you
have 100,000 plus minus whatever
depending on ethnicity or whatever um uh
hair follicles on your head and Visually
if you pull one out you don't notice any
difference in the mirror obviously but
over time the miniaturization of these
follicles will create a visual
perception that becomes atically
significant after years of it happening
to where all of a sudden one day you
know in downlighting or a picture or
whatever you start to notice oh I can
see my scalp and I couldn't see it
before oh my I didn't even notice this
was happening and usually it's like a
pretty startling moment when people
realize like oh [__] I actually am prone
to hair loss and it's happening but by
then you've already lost like 20 30 plus
perc of your hair and often times people
will give you bad feedback you'll be
like do you think I'm losing hair'll be
like no it looks fine it's like no dude
you are not fine it has been happening
insidiously this whole time so a reality
check sometimes is that you know
recession isn't just indicative of oh
it's what happens to adults and it's
supposed to like there are people like
Ronald Reagan who end up at 80 n what
whatever he lived to and had perfect
hairline now I'm not saying he used
drugs to do it he's obviously a genetic
freak but at the end of the day if you
intervene early enough you could prevent
you getting to that point in the time
frame that you would have otherwise if
not saved it off entirely so so getting
in front of it is so much better than
trying to make backr cuz trying to
recover dead zones on your scalp
especially is like very difficult even
with drugs so how do you get in front of
it what's your recommendation to someone
who's probably in their 20s maybe
starting to notice this what we okay
let's use me for an example here I
brought this up to Graham he's like no
no you're totally fine he did what you
just said obviously I like I'll show off
my hair right so see how like at the
corner see how it's coming up a little
bit right here coming up a little bit
right here I'm mostly fine like I I feel
like so confident with my hair but I'm
very worried that I will eventually lose
it that for me is like horrifying and
when I did start to notice like in the
corners right here like it coming up a
little bit it was like startling like
you said it was shocking with you too if
you want to know if you're prone rather
than getting on drugs that you might be
worried about you could take good
pictures in track over time and at the
first sign of further recession that
could be your sign okay now I start
taking it cuz you could still like
barely have any more loss and get in
front of it before it's so bad that it's
obvious cuz for you like you're pretty
good right now so if it were me and I
was like actually averse to taking drugs
I would take a picture and find some
Landmark on your scalp that you could
use as a reference point of recession
and then use that as a gauge for as you
get older is that you know taking
progress pictures once a month or
something is that Landmark are you
getting more recessed in that area
relative to whatever thing you use as
Landmark often people will find like a
freckle or something something you
should be able to use to figure it out
and at that point if you're further
receding at some rate that is you know
noticeable at all like you know that
you're on your way there at you know a
significant enough Pace that it's going
to be okay well when I'm 30 plus or
however old you'll be able to see it
probably so do I care enough at that
point to get in front of it with drugs
knowing that it's happening CU some
people could hypothetically get on drugs
and maybe not have needed to the
likelihood is low because most people
will end up with some degree of hair
loss it's just to what significance
level will be dictated by genetics so
like Ronald Reagan didn't even need to
take anything almost certainly I
guarantee almost guarantee he was not on
hair loss prevention drugs Alex horos
dude hairline it like goes like down
it's like he's got like maybe he's got a
negative hairline yeah and he'll be like
what do you do and he'll be like nothing
yeah he' be like yeah he'll be like what
a ridiculous question what do you mean
your hair's perfect you [__] so yeah he
doesn't uh he doesn't do anything so
that's genetics for example but again
with him you don't actually know that I
don't know what his dad looks like maybe
one day all of a sudden you know the
switch flips because there are
epigenetics that could you know at some
point the rate of Aging or his just the
process of Aging could trigger certain
things that otherwise were not
problematic so you could end up in a
state of accelerated energenic alipa I
think that's actually a thing where I
couldn't point to literature that proves
it but it seems like at some point some
people do experience like acceleration
or deceleration of certain things in the
body depending on environmental
conditions what have you but it's also I
think genes can turn on and off
depending on certain circumstances and
certain switches could flip in a way
that all of a sudden now it's like now
it's started for him is that why they
say stress exaggerates hair loss stress
is more shedding so it's called telen
effluvium and there's a difference
between shedding and actual hair loss
because when you Shed from stress often
times you will see it come out in clumps
in areas that are localized not
necessarily like symmetrically all the
way across your scalp so androgenic
alopecia you'll see like a pattern of
recession that is very indicative of
like DHT affecting it versus if you had
just like a bout of horrendous stress
like for example I had a friend who when
he was trying to become a firefighter he
was getting hazed like crazy and he
literally had like a patch fall out of
the side of his head and it grew back
white and eventually it came back but
like that's an example of alip Tia
caused by stress like it was not a
uniform recession pattern that is
indicative of androgens so people have
to remember there's a difference between
hair loss and androgenic alopecia which
is like Androgen induced alopecia
alopecia being hair loss so to in get in
front of androgenic alopecia which is
the thing most guys deal with that is
typically hormonal so in your case I
would use you know tracking to actually
decide if you want to take drugs or not
or if it's even necessary and then at
that point if it still happening you're
like okay what I want to get in front of
it now how do I do it the number one
thing that is the most impactful is
something called finasteride sure you
guys have heard of it inhibits the
production of something called DHT which
is the primary hormone that dictates
masculine characteristics like in
adolescence the thing that will
differentiate and mature you as a male
is DHT the most if you don't have any
DHT you will end up with a micropenis an
array of features that are not
representative of like a fully grown
male so DHT is like the opposite hormone
to estrogen essentially and
testosterone's like somewhat not in the
middle but it's like on the spectrum of
Androgen versus estrogen feminine vers
mass and you can like you see this all
the time in bodybuilding or in
transitioning individuals manual
manipulation of this that shows that
even in adulthood people who are
manually use using these hormones can
literally like flip-flop genders
essentially because it's like there's
nothing really differentiating somebody
other than like anatomically to some
extent but also in adolescence if you
expose some girl to hyper androgenic
state with exogenous hormones you could
literally make her seem like a dude to
any objective metric of somebody seeing
her they' be like that's 100% a guy even
though she might not be so like these
things can be manipulated to where if
you take finasteride this hormone DHT
really has no impact on muscle growth
strength the thing it mainly dictates is
sebum production which is like oil in
the skin essentially um prostate size um
it inhibits estrogen's activities in
some tissues it does it does things that
are important but it's more primarily an
adolescence where you don't want to be
inhibiting it because you will end up in
a you may end up in a state of like
hinder development essentially to say
the least but in adulthood when you take
it you could prevent the further
miniaturization of hair follicles key
note being the further miniaturization
you're not going to necessarily reverse
miniaturization you might get some
regrowth as you inhibit the process of
Expediting itself But ultimately once
you implement this blockade of hormone
essentially it becomes far more
difficult to miniaturize at all because
even in studies we'll see individuals
with deficiencies and the enzyme that
makes this hormone no temporal recession
at all less body hair like everything
about them is slightly less masculine by
metrics of like male secondary sexual
characteristics but they never lose
their hair so it's like if you can
replicate at that to some extent that is
non- impactful from a side effect
context you can kind of replicate that
state to some extent in adulthood after
you fully developed and that so isn't
that just about waiting until you're
already fully developed to start finast
ride yeah so like ideally you would wait
until you're a full- grown adult and
then you would get on it if you need it
um the problem is that it's not a side
effect free drug and some people end up
with pretty significant issues Al but a
minority they're a very outspoken
minority and justifiably so because they
have some pretty significant issues
sometimes no one should ever say like
mindly this is 100% safe you will be
fine the likelihood is high you'll have
no issues like objectively by data it's
like very unlikely of issues but there
is a possibility so if you have none of
the negative side effects is there
anything just bad about putting in some
manufactured thing into your system like
a synthetic drug sure or just like just
finasteride in general like if the
studies are showing the data is showing
that the likelihood of some negative
byproduct to take this thing the
negative symptom is so small and you
don't get any of those then would you
say it's fine if you want to just take
your chances yeah if you have no side
effects for sure get on that [__] I'm on
duas ride which is like the even more
aggressive format of finastra that
inhibits almost all of my DHT like my
hormone levels on paper look like a girl
for DHD and yet I'm sitting here with a
masculine voice my brain's working well
at least to date knock on wood uh muscle
is fine like nothing is perceivably
wrong that would justify me coming off
and a lot of people are similar in that
aspect so I'm not say that I'm the you
know reference case whatsoever but just
giving like an anecdote of even in the
hyper extreme some people use dast ride
too which is like an even more
aggressive drug and have no issues
there's like one guy who has a
registered IQ that's like second best on
the planet and he's been on dast ride
for decades not to say that's a
justification for it but you know it's
good to see both sides of the coin
because you often hear the horror
stories the thing with the internet the
most outspoken people are not the people
who take drugs and get results and just
like don't care about it anymore it's
people who tried something and had a
horrendous outcome and want to warn the
world about it which is fine and I think
they should but when you take something
like for example if you took Tylenol and
it got rid of your headache are you
going to go on Reddit and be like took
Tylenol it was great you know got rid of
my headache of course not so with hair
loss a lot of guys they're like oh I
heard I was should take finra I saw an
ad on Philip def Franco's show for you
know keeps or something I'm going to
just jump on it they get on it stops
their hair loss and you never hear from
them again and they never post about it
because why would they but then people
who take it the you know whatever
percent of people and they have some
either some minor issue or a significant
issue that is like very noticeable
they're on the internet [__] talking
about it how do I fix it talking with
other people your experience was this oh
this happened to me and I get it but at
the same time I think it's almost like
the positive results are under
represented yeah anecdotally I've talked
to a lot of people who are on finast
ride and from everyone that I've talked
to only one person said they knew of
someone who had negative effects and
that stopped as soon as they stopped
taking it and part of the issue too is
now with the Internet it's so well known
this stuff that a lot of people Placebo
themselves into side effects yeah so I'm
not to say that the side effects aren't
real I know of people that I don't think
are just Placebo that have pretty
significant issues but a lot of it is
like people do just fine and a lot of
people who do have issues they're like I
think something's I think my erection
quality is worse than it was but I'm not
really sure I'm like is it really like
if you I have benchmarks yeah take the
photo
mon they got to do the Brian Johnson
thing where they like measure their pen
every night but what about red light
therapy uh Jack and I were actually at
the gym this was maybe two months ago
and the guy from Iris store came up to
me and said I'd love to give you the
helmet just try it out uh we're not
going to ask anything of you I just want
to give this to you let us know what you
think and so I've been trying it but
it's too early to tell yeah for me what
I have noticed is almost nothing so I
have the most expensive custom version
of that that helmet made by a guy who
literally all he does is man sit at home
and create these with actual there's
like a difference between the lasers
that are impactful on actually achieving
the outcome you want versus like as far
as I know there's LEDs and lasers and
what you want to get is as dense of a
concentration of these certain lasers
that impact the metrics of hair growth
that you're trying to get out of it and
some of it is like the iror stuff a lot
of it is margin
consideration oriented cuz it's like
they have to market the [__] of this
thing and they can't afford the best
most intensive device possible plus all
the marketing that goes into selling it
plus maintain the margin and hair growth
is such a slow and kind of like
ambiguous process that it's very easy to
even get Placebo into thinking it's
working because you had a good hair day
or whatever but most people who use it
don't sustain therapy so there's like a
copout even where you probably didn't
use it properly and then in addition to
that it's not guaranteed to work for
everyone is what they'll maybe assert at
best but in general I have never seen
anybody in my life and I've looked into
this [__] to no end have such a
significant result that it like
completely averted the necessity to use
actual therapies that move the needle so
it was typically an adjunct that some
people claim might have helped to some
extent but to put into perspective like
this stuff very I spent a significant
amount of time researching it and
spending my own money on things that I
wanted to see how well they worked and
like I spent I don't know like $2,000 on
some device that was custom made with
the most dense concentration of lasers
you could possibly get legally and I
didn't notice anything now did I use it
long enough did I do it properly you
know if I didn't I don't think I would
have seen if I continued like even it
was just annoying to use too like that's
a significant hindrance for me to add
anything to my routine that is different
now it's not easy to work when I have
this thing on my head at least I found
see I put on before going to bed or
watching some TV or something like that
I put on 12 minutes I'm going to give it
six months okay see what happens I think
a maybe like a month into it so we'll
see yeah the iris store if you don't
have like an actual metric to go by to
it's very difficult to know that it
worked or not CU there is like a um hair
hair analysis you could do to actually
see per square centimeter like how many
hairs are there versus before and after
and that's how they'll assess treatment
validity clinically and with this stuff
it's like you're just going to go
objectively by what your hair looks like
in the mirror and the likely outcome is
you might be like I don't know it might
have helped might have not and it's like
for something to take up like however
many minutes of your life on a day every
other day or daily basis it's like is
that worth 1% of results typically I
would say no and that's even me who
cares about this stuff a lot sure yeah
that's fair what do you think the
obsession is it seems in social media
with
testosterone yeah like I don't know what
spurred it for sure like ultimately it
is the hormone that dictates muscle
growth potential relative to your
response to it so I could see why people
would focus on it but it's interesting
that it gets the hype it does because
there are other hormones that are just
as impactful in their own unique ways
like estrogen or whatever and no one
really talks about those but yeah
testosterone is um if you're low it'll
you know mess with your life pretty
significantly you'll have a harder time
building muscle libido down Etc so seems
like I've had a lot of friends too that
have all recently gotten tested and
they're like oh my gosh I had no idea my
testosterone was this low I you know it
explains so much so I went and got
tested and I thought oh man like maybe
if my motivation isn't as good I'm not
putting on as much muscle in the gym
like maybe I have low testosterone then
I was also concerned that I've never
been able to grow a beard and I was
thinking oh crap like I for sure have
low testosterone it came back like 800
and something like on the really high
end and so then I was like well you know
that doesn't explain I can't grow a
beard is that just genetic yeah so jeans
will dictate often how
your predisposition to certain things
are like Asians you will typically never
see with thick body hair do they all
have low test no you know some of them
it's just the way their skin I could I
could probably find the answer if I dug
in and found like what is it about them
that causes less uh you know
proliferation of like air follicle
development or whatever but in general
your hormones are going to enhance
whatever your potential is but like for
example if I if you shot yourself with
Mr Olympia level steroid dosages you
would not necessarily look even a
semblance like them you would max out
whatever you could get to with your
genetics but ultimately those are your
genetics just like hormos shows up with
a 120 test and the guy's yoked out of
his tree you know like that guy if he
gets on testosterone his 800 that he's
manually adjusted to is like the
equivalent of another guy with actual
above average genetics getting on grams
and grams of stuff so the difference in
genetic uh response is H huge and then
also it's your body's regulating
feedback in which it determines how much
you need to fulfill functions so just
because your testies shoot out 800 first
of all it's a snapshot in time it
fluctuates wildly over the day so you
could have 800 at the time you tested it
but it could dip up and down throughout
the day like 300 oh doesn't doesn't mean
that it's like good or bad necessarily
and there is ways to use those numbers
as guidance tools of like generally does
this kind of like respond to why I feel
a certain way I kind of understand like
what's going on it is useful but the
number doesn't always mean everything so
like I know guys who have 500 total test
that are way more jacked than guys who
have a thousand MH it's just like your
response and it's not even just muscle
it's also like psychoactive activity
it's your um I don't know ability to
support bone strength it's like there's
a ton of processes that are partially
determined by testosterone and your body
the way it produces things it's based on
what it thinks you need based on the
circumstance you've imposed on it so for
you to achieve whatever outcome your
body deems as ideal it's shooting out
800 for another guy it might be 400 for
another guy might be 1,200 it depends on
the person so and that's not good or bad
it can be used as a proxy for assessing
in general does this look low and maybe
that's explaining why I feel a certain
way and have symptoms but if you're
symptom free and your testosterone's
like 470 for example I wouldn't tell
that that guy like oh you're on the lsh
end you should probably take
testosterone I certainly would not do
that so what are
symptoms um morning wood being gone is a
pretty common one um erectile
dysfunction lack of uh Drive motivation
General feelings of being tired all the
time unexplainably emotional volatility
lack of ability to build muscle all of a
sudden you're losing strength in the gym
or it's harder to put on muscle or keep
off fat um there's a lot of metrics that
are kind of vague sounding like how am I
going to look in the gym it's kind of
arbitrary yeah so that's kind of where
the blood work helps correspond with the
symptoms so if you generally feel not
great it's worth checking and especially
one of the easiest ways to tell in my
opinion is like erectile quality and
libido and drive that's kind of like one
of the main the main things I use as a
tool for like like no guy should be
waking up or trying to have sex with his
wife or whatever and like being
incapable of doing so they might have a
vascular problem which you know a lot of
guys have heart disease or are on their
way there so that might be causing the
erection issues too but that's where the
blood work helps cuz it's like oh well
my testosterone levels look normal as do
the other hormones in that
subsystem but my other markers that are
like circulatory look mangled and then
it's like okay well is that the cause of
my erection issues maybe it's not the
testosterone so it blood work ultimately
is useful to actually get really
granular and figure out what is wrong
with me and why or where could I
optimize should I optimize and getting
like a full picture do you feel like
people are using testosterone now as
almost a Band-Aid to improve their life
in some sort of way mhm yeah I think
especially in the
entrepreneur side of things these guys
are like and again it's like is that bad
necessarily who am I to say that you
shouldn't do that it's your body you can
do whatever you want but yeah like I
think a lot of people are the sexy idea
of trt like oh you know it's going to
help enhance my mental Drive
productivity muscle growth Etc certainly
could I'm not to say it's not like it
actually is impactful especially as you
get 35 Plus you will reliably in general
this isn't everyone though your
testosterone may go down upwards of like
a percent a year in perpetuity that's
just you deteriorating as a human
unfortunately and at that point is it
unwarranted to supplement back up to
what you were when you were 21 I know
it's like for some people they're
definitely in that Fringe like weird
gray area where it's like you know like
I feel pretty okay but like I probably
don't need it but maybe it would help
and it's kind of like there's no like
real way to define at that point should
I be doing it or not all you need to
know is what goes into it though and
what circumstance you're imposing on
yourself and the risk to make that
decision and then you have to make an
educated uh path forward yourself
essentially because it's like okay do I
care about now having to monitor my
fertility metrics all the time and do I
want to have a kid when do I want to
have a kid um do I care about having to
monitor my blood work to make sure that
my ection schedule isn't resulting in
too much red blood cell production I'm
going to like increase my chance of a
heart attack there are certain things
that you got to be mindful of um do I
want to be injecting something for the
rest of my life you know do I want to be
uh have atrophy testicles which can be
you can do things to make sure that
doesn't happen but like there are
considerations I all of a sudden your
life involves many more things to look
at that you didn't even think about
before what about other things that
people ingest like like weed or alcohol
or or micro doing even micro doing what
are your thoughts on those things I
don't know if you partake in in any of
those things in general for anything
that is not enhancing of like
productivity and could cloud my mind or
I don't know some people could assert
that they're like creativity enhancing
but that doesn't really help me as much
at least what I've determined in my work
so I don't micro do with anything I
don't use psychedelics I don't smoke
weed I don't want something that messes
with my Hunger I don't want something
that messes with my sleep quality which
weed will do to some extent um to me
it's never been those aren't drugs that
I even really look at that closely
because I they don't aren't conducive to
the state of mind or state of uh just
whole
body anything that I want to be in so
will they be impactful on hormone levels
though if that's the question or just
just in general I also saw I remember
like for some reason I think about this
still to this day uh Steve will do it
said do you know who that is so he said
I only got to work out high if I'm
working out High you know I'm going to
have a good
workout impression thank you yeah so he
like Feels Like Jesus man come on dude
you feel like you got to really break
those out right now Jack ask him the
question you've been curious about this
question first I got to do this though
oh you know we're all we're all doing
this yeah how often do you look in the
mirror and flex not as much as I used to
yeah I I don't know five times a day
no no no you guys just had hormos on so
this is not even like a comparable
situation I'm curious in my situation I
go to the gym pretty much every day I do
20 minutes of cardio in that workout
which is usually about an hour I think I
eat pretty healthy I don't eat dessert
most of the time I try to stay away from
sugars I cannot seem to lose the belly
fat that that obscures the lower like
you know third of the ABS mhm it's been
like a year no matter what I do it seems
like it's hopeless and do you count
calories
no dude that's I don't but like
objectively I'm not eating that much so
like I kind of think you know if if I'm
on the treadmill for 20 minutes on the
highest incline I know I burned 200
calories on that thing I'm working out
I'm not eating that much you know the
coffee I barely put any creamer on the
coffee like I'm just
thinking it I should be seeing some
results here how many grams of protein
do you eat per day and how many calories
do you eat can you answer either of
those no uh I would I would guess within
a range but I wouldn't answer precisely
well there you go so like often times
what people find is at the end of the
day if I'm let's just say my maintenance
calories which is the calories I need to
maintain my body weight let's just say
it's like 2800 for example with my
exercise and everything I'm doing a lot
of times what people will end up is in a
situation where they
are very close to their goal and then
wreck it with like minor little things
that they're not accounting for not
counting very basic condiments stuff
they're putting in [__] little things
that all add up and that compounded over
time similarly to investing equates to
an outcome that is not optimal however
if you're even in like a 200 calorie
deficit which is not that hard to dollar
cost average in your diet right over
time the compounded outcome is you being
losing multiple pounds over the space of
a year to where your body composition at
the end is you you know having
satisfactory results versus you having
no results so it's like the in the
micro the the little choices that you're
not counting like the fact that you've
even told me you're not able to you
don't know what the calories are exactly
but you're pretty sure you're in the
range of but you're not able to lose the
weight that you want to lose or you're
not able to gain the muscle you want and
your hormones look good on paper again
obviously there's response to the
hormones can differ But ultimately if
you have not counted meticulously like
if you are counting with extreme
scrutiny it's literally a physical
impossibility to not lose away do you
think there's anything any Merit to
let's say not eating enough and your
body's kind of like holding on to what
it has because it's like you're eating
it random times or I'm not eating for
the first half of the day like you're
either expending more than you're taking
in or you're not like there's a very
like it's you know and then one or the
other what about not drinking water cuz
I realized all day today except for a
little bit this morning I'm not had any
water just besides yeah sound great
that's what I tell him that is like one
of my main water I don't think you're
going to like not lose weight because of
inadequate hydration though but what I
would do that's a really good hack is
get a water bottle that is like big
enough that you only need to refill it
once a day or something I did that I did
that I went on Amazon I got the one
where it's like a gallon or it's like a
gallon and a half or whatever it was and
there are different markers that say
like by this time drink this much by
this much and I did it for a few days
but I was just peeing like five times
you know before noon it was it it got
too distracting cuz like every 30
minutes I just have to get up and go pee
we stagger it out more maybe I don't
know like ultimately there's a certain
amount of hydration you need and then if
you're pissing it all out like I would
wonder you know like what are you eating
that is but you know what maybe for me
I'm smaller so I don't need the full
gallon a l yeah there's General there's
general rules to follow I could pull up
the calculation I forgot what it is
that's like a good General range of a
like a Target each day but yeah man like
ultimately if you're counting
meticulously like you can pretty
reliably determine even how fast you
will lose so I don't know if you track
the scale closely but you should be
weighing yourself once when you wake up
after you take your morning piss that's
your metric that you're using and over
the week you will have an average of
numbers that you either gained or lost
and yeah the number will fluctuate Up
and Down based on water retention food
that's in your stomach versus not at
some points and that's why some days you
might actually gain weight even though
you eight in a deficit but over the
average of the week you will lose weight
if you're in a deficit in general yeah I
think the only way could be screwing
this up honestly is just all you could
eat sushi at the one time I would
also say that if you're not tracking
your protein similar to what you asked
earlier about if I'm eating in a deficit
doesn't matter if it's Oreos or whatever
yeah it will affect your body
composition so even if you lose weight
you don't want to end up skinny fat
which is a situation a lot of people end
up in where they're like inadequately
muscled but they've lost weight but a
lot of it was lean muscle that they
relied on that was expending calories at
rest cuz muscle is metabolically active
tissue that while you're sitting here is
burning up more calories than you're fat
so like being as muscle bound as
possible is like pretty key too for more
sustainably staying lean and it's just
healthier than having fat on your body
to be H so that protein calorie counting
but also I don't know what your training
is like but I think a lot of people
Overlook the importance of like tracking
the weight so keeping a log book even if
it's seems cumbersome and annoying if
you're not like actually holding
yourself to a standard of progressively
overloading you're not giving your body
reason to adapt so you could go in the
gym and actually work pretty hard but if
it's not something that is over the
threshold of necessary to stimulate
further growth you will kind of be not
making progress regardless of everything
else looks good like you could you could
lose weight and like you know achieve
certain metrics but you'll never
optimize if you're not trying to gain
muscle progressively overloading
tracking numbers and yeah some people
can intuitively do that some people need
to write it down and I don't think
that's a problem like if you're in the
gym and last week you did you know 50
pounds on the dumbbell press for 12 reps
per set like next time try 55 on set one
and then do like you know 50/50 or
whatever and like try to you just have
to impose constant levels of adaptation
similar to what you do in anything in
life you're not going to adapt if you
don't push yourself into uncomfortable
state to some extent so got it I think
Graham also needs to do legs he never
does legs and and wouldn't legs be good
for weight loss because like you said if
you have muscles they metabolize faster
than fat so if he had muscles on his
legs yeah then it would be good for
weight loss yeah assuming you're that's
a pretty big muscle group to skip so why
are you going to call me out like that
Jack got to edit that out I'm trying to
provide constructive criticism but wood
wood working out legs that's good for
weight loss right oh 100% yeah but you
can also work out legs on the incline on
the treadmill right at 15 inclines so
like the top incline that does something
though right that's pretty defin it's
better than sitting yeah for sure so
technically what you could do I don't
like this it didn't work out for me and
I'd never use it but it's a desk that
you can move to standing and then
putting like a small treadmill in it or
something so whenever you're doing I
can't focus when I do this but some
people do great when you're doing like
tedious meetings that you don't
necessarily need to have like per
perfect sound quality or potentially if
you're just like reading through emails
or reading reports that you could focus
on that don't require like the most
intensive attention getting steps in
while you are working could be done too
it's just like yeah I don't know prepare
for podcast is always on the treadmill
and I just download videos and I watch
them okay there you go yeah but yeah man
like uh download Like My Fitness Pal or
something like a free app and you just
track the calories and it'll make a
difference yeah what do you think about
adderal negative side effects do some
people need it do some people not need
it is it overprescribed how do you know
when you need it how consistently should
you take it if you're taking it all
right let me try I have a lot I have a
lot of questions and i' I've I've spoke
about this actually in a brand deal that
we had with with better help but I said
that so I I was diagnosed with ADHD and
I got prescribed Aderall I took it for
about two years straight every single
day uh I was probably 19 to 21 or maybe
maybe 20 to 22 what was your dose uh I
initially started out I think
at 10 mhm and then I got up to 20 XR and
I was taking 20 XR every day yeah so
there's a few things I could say I think
it is overprescribed first of all mhm I
think a lot of people think that uh they
have ADHD when they might just have like
bad sleep patterns or poor lifestyle CU
like at the end of the day the thing
that's the most impactful on your
cognitive state is going to be diet um
exercise sleep like you could take any
amount of drugs it will not make up for
those things as like boring as that
might sound um even when you look to
literature you can offset deficits and
performance when you're sleep deprived
through these drugs often like mapol and
whatnot but you will not really enhance
your state above Baseline at least by
studies if you are well slept and like
in a good state for working but you know
I think it is overprescribed I think a
lot of people are using it unnecessarily
I think a lot of people think that they
tie good outcomes to it because they
used it and then something good happened
while they were on it or they felt like
they were more productive while they
were on it so then they need it and they
tie that to that activity to like I need
it in order to work now it's almost like
the crutches like hor MOSI talks about
like you don't want to be the guy who
needs Aderall to like do good business
you know that guy's going to get
decimated by a guy like Alex who can be
underslept and doesn't need anything so
with that it's like yeah there are
negative side effects it will reliably
increase your heart rate blood pressure
um while in general that could be
relatively benign in the short term and
like the studies they look at in the
long term that compounded with
everything else it's just another risk
factor that you're adding into the
equation and with XR in particular it's
called halflife it's like how long it
takes for half the drug to work its way
out of your system that halflife is so
long that it's almost certainly
impacting Your Sleep Quality to where
it's like a vicious circle effect where
you take it in order to be as
cognitively dialed as you can it's still
in your system when you go to bed you
get poor sleep and then you need Aderall
to fix your state because you feel like
you're not sharp enough and then you
just keep it keeps going so I see a lot
of people end up on really high dosages
and yet their state of mind at the point
they got to is often worse than them at
Baseline like before they even started
it so I'm not to say it doesn't have
utility at all I think in certain
circumstances like if you are sleep
deprived to hell and you like need to
attenuate the deficit in performance
because you're about to do something
that is you know you can't not perform
like you know could be worthwhile and it
definitely shows in the literature that
is like caffeine maol all these things
can make up for deficits in sleep in the
short term but at the end of the day it
could be at the expense of tomorrow's
sleep and then in perpetuity thereafter
if you continue to push it down that
road so um and also stimulating like
synthetic release of dopamine and like
stress hormones or kind of like fighter
flight hormones
um neurotransmitters that are like
stress inducing aren't necessarily
always conducive to high quality work
sometimes you might feel like you're
revved up and you're mentally driven but
you're kind of like some people just end
up more all over the place in addition
at least for me Aderall makes my libido
go through the roof so for me I actually
get almost preoccupied with sex when I
take it to the point that it's like
whatever increase in performance I might
get is offset entirely by me wanting to
bang my girlfriend like three times and
that's not good for work you know it's
hard to focus when that's happening so
like I know some guys who literally say
when they take it they just end up
jerking off all day instead of working
that's an actual outcome that happens
yeah that's that's crazy yeah because
it's like when you're flooding your
brain with like Feelgood dopaminergic
activity yeah it's not necessarily
always going to translate into like I'm
going to make good YouTube videos or I'm
going to write a good paper for school
is that just discipline or is that how
the mind is WI it depends on the person
okay yeah cuz like some people take it
and don't get an effect on appetite too
but a lot of people me included if I
take it I have no appetite I could not
eat pretty much all day and that's
another way people abuse it especially
in the fitness industry is they take
they either smoke or they take a lot of
nicotine or a lot of caffeine or Aderall
they will crush their appetite in order
to not eat and they take steroids to
offset the loss and lean muscle and they
will basically get be like shredded all
the time and offset any like
deterioration of performance at least
they try to through like stimulants
steroids Etc so you know that's all to
say that if you have ADHD and you need
it like I'm sure there is an actual
utility where it is needed because there
are certain people with certain genetic
predispositions neurologically that I
couldn't speak to like you are lying
about your situation like they probably
need it but I think a lot of times it is
too general of a classification that
doesn't take into account like all of
the variables because when you go in for
an Aderall like assessment if you are
somebody with ADHD for riddlin or viance
or any of this stuff they're not going
to ask you like have you tried
optimizing your sleep yet like what's
your diet and then yeah it'd be like
write this checklist and it's like do
you
feel I don't know unproductive or do you
feel like you get distracted more than x
times per day or whatever and it's like
I kind of I get it but at the same time
it's like I think a lot of people are
getting on it that don't need it and I
think a lot of people are using it for
the purposes at which I don't know in
the short term for certain like
circumstances it could be helpful but
like it's certainly not an everyday Med
that you would want to do so I think my
concern with adderal and everybody
thinking they have ADHD because if you
talk to people that are my age I'm sure
a lot of the commentors can attest to
this everybody thinks that they have
ADHD but I think that it's more just a
cause of spending so much time on like
Tik Tok Instagram with commercials
distractions all of these things that
give you instant gratification kind of
turn you into a proxy ADHD person
but then it was actually when I started
going to therapy as actually better help
they pointed out some things where
before I had Tik Tok and all these
distractions and I couldn't watch TV
until a certain time of day it's like
did you experience this when you were a
kid and it's like actual things that are
indicative of it and I relate it to when
I was a kid that for me was like the
most mind-blowing but I feel like
everybody thinks nowadays that they
suffer from ADHD or just have it I
shouldn't say suffer from yeah like a
lot of people I know now have burner
phones intentionally so the only thing
their phone does is like emergency
functions and then the the phone that
has social media and stuff on it for
work is not around unless they're
posting and then they get rid of it
immediately like Joe Rogan for example
he has a burner phone and has like
nothing on it and that's that make a
great product it's just a like a really
nice that ladybug thing yeah it's like
an optimized phone without any apps or
anything where it's just a phone and
texting that's it doesn't let you
download the stuff you mean like it's
just like it's just there is one of
those actually I saw it it's a
commercial it's like also in black and
white yeah one of the hacks too that I
got from Alex is you go into your color
uh settings in your phone and you can
turn it on Gray scale and like cuts the
dopamine kind of Spike from social media
a decent amount yeah you just want to
spend less time on yeah yeah it's like
far less interesting to scroll
mindlessly when you have like no Vivid
colors blasting in your face yeah so
like there's stuff you can do it's just
like obviously takes discipline too to
even avoid like don't go get the actual
phone like leave it yeah you know isn't
it better though just to practice
discipline at the end of the day of just
setting boundaries for yourself and
sticking with it what I will say though
dude is as much as I would love to say
that everyone just needs to like you
know get their [__] together and be as
disciplined as possible some of the most
respected people some of the people I
respect the most in Health Fitness
whatever they also just like employ
practices of not having it in the house
to not have to deal with it like their
strategy is ultimately don't have it
around as much as I want to say like do
you guys just have like the insane
mental fortitude and you haven't like
ate shitty for so long that you just
don't care about it anymore they're like
no I actually like don't have it in the
house cuz if I do I will eat it I'm like
damn even like the most respected
qualified guys yeah that's kind of like
me with desserts or sweets it it's the
sweets that you can't stop with just one
like having M&M's or Oreos and things
like this I really try not to keep them
in the house cuz it's so easy just to
eat one
and then one more and one more and one's
not bad but it just it rarely ever stops
at one and like you only have so much
mental fortitude that gets chopped away
at over the day that you know this is
why people often snack at night time or
do whatever and like make you know uh I
don't know like a they will basically
cave at the end of the day on themselves
and like completely [__] up their diets
for an array of different things but the
less things you have to impose on your
environment that make you have to dig
into that mental fortitude like the EAS
easier it is to just like smoothly
cruise through life and not cheat on the
diet for example so yeah like Peter AA
for example super respected guy he has
multiple kids who do sometimes eat good
snacks and now what they do is they take
the kids out for ice cream whenever they
want ice cream not have ice cream in the
house like he will drive them to an ice
cream place and get them ice cream but
he won't have drumsticks in the freezer
because he will decimate them self
admittedly which I think is cool because
a lot of guys could act like and very
much would like I'm this hard guy and
like I have the insane mental fortitude
and just don't be a [__] don't eat
drunk how could you you know just just
don't do it easier said than done for a
lot of people so like for me I try to I
try my best to not have stuff in the
house it's like my hack if you even call
it that Peter also brushes his teeth
right after dinner like he does his
whole like brush routine right after he
finishes eating because if you're around
for hours before you go to bed you're
more likely to cheat skip yeah so it's
like trying to impose on yourself having
that you feel like a double idiot if you
brush
and to do it because to eat ANM or I
feel like David gogin is the only out
there with real discipline imagine that
he actually was like totally snacking
yeah yeah but that guy is like it's wild
too cuz I've I asked Joe like I don't
know David myself but I was like is
there any like pivotal event that kind
of like he was self admittedly ACC used
to be fat out of shape and something
triggered in him that made him adopt
this hyper disciplined like approach to
life and you perhaps it's in his book
and I should just read the book but it's
like it's interesting how some people
are you know not the representation of
health and discipline and they even
pivot thereafter despite having Decades
of like bad habits so obviously it's
something you can change but I certainly
wouldn't use David is like the reference
of like he does this so I should be able
to like keep drunk in my house do this
do that and just avoid everything bad I
don't think that's the reasonable goal
for most people how do you think you can
increase dis discipline for people
because I know so many people and I
think discipline is just plummeting I
think it's like I mean it's like bad how
quickly it's just falling off a cliff
how can people hopefully grab onto the
discipline and like bring it back up
there um I do think that maybe as
redundant as it is imposing less
situations where you have to dig into
like situations that require your mental
bandwidth allocation to be disciplined
equals a greater amount of like resource
to allocate to actual things that are
worthwhile rather than like literally
thinking in my mind how to avoid a
drumstick in my freezer like just don't
have it in the house like that's
something that I think is reasonable um
I think also setting like micro
achievable goals that you can get that
feedback from is worthwhile so like if
you don't go to the gym at all rather
than expecting yourself to be in this
perfect you know routine immediately
just like let's just show up you know
show up and like get on a treadmill or
something like just getting to the gym
is like a you know a task in itself for
some people as absurd as it sounds and
just setting like progressively
overloading your goals as dumb and
workout bro as that sounds it's totally
applicable you know like even when
you're setting your goals for the year
if I want to hit this many subscribers
or I want to get this or I want to do
that like a lot of things are more
daunting in the macro but when you get
granular on the micro like they're far
more achievable and a lot more easy to
wrap your head around how you could
actually get to the macro goal when you
look at look at all these micro
increments that if I just hit these at
the end of the day have compounded to
this like finality and conclusive
outcome that is huge so like you know
for me I even try to get granular about
like how much you know how many if I was
posting regularly how many views do I
think it's reasonable to get like per
day or like what's a subscriber per day
metric that's is I think good to achieve
good growth of the brand or Revenue per
day that is going to be sustainable to
achieve this end outcome at the end of
the year that I think is a good year
like I don't look at I don't really look
as much at the end year number as I do
on the micro what do I need to do like
this week to actually equate to the
habits that would result in that final
outcome and I think it's a lot easier
for people to actually get out of a funk
or discipline themselves to start
because otherwise it's too daunting to
even do anything seemingly um so those
are two things that I think are pretty
actionable um but um also it's like the
lifestyle things we talked about like if
you're low on sleep like good luck you
know you're it's going to be far more
difficult to make rational decisions
you're going to be more emotionally
volatile it'll be you almost can't even
trust your mindset when you are in a
suboptimal state of health so I think
just getting as healthy as you can and
dialing in things that are really low
hanging fruit like everyone's bed is in
their house everyone is capable of
getting in it and getting eight hours
it's just like most don't so you know
that kind of stuff makes a big
difference too on your decision making
process and am I going to sit here and
play video games because I'm kind of
like feeling down and I kind of want
that dopamine hit of whatever versus am
I gonna go work so hopefully that's
helpful for some people it sounds like
the main thing here is sleep like that's
the thing that you consistently bring up
over and over and over again and I'll
say in my own life I've tried so many
different hacks to try to improve like
the way that I feel when I wake up in
the morning or just like maybe my
overall mental well-being and the three
things I've noticed actually have an
impact cuz usually I don't see any
results with all the things I've tried
is sleep diet and resistance training
there you go those are the three things
and sleep is so but sometimes you could
sleep too much and I feel just as bad
sleeping too much as I do under sleeping
that's also probably a bit psychological
too because you know you just wasted
part of your valuable day so I'm not
necessarily saying you should oversleep
by any means you should go by like
metrics of like you can tell when you've
had a good sleep and sometimes it's not
always reflected by the number so like
if you get up at 7 hours and you feel
great it doesn't necessarily mean you
have to force yourself to stay in bed
for 8 and if you feel feel underslept at
eight maybe you need nine that day I
don't think people need to get too
hypers specific about this but it's
worth like whatever you need getting it
I think is like at least worth seeing on
a regular B basis what's my month look
like with actually trying to hit at
least eight hours or whatever makes me
feel good and not making myself get out
of bed when the alarm goes off that I
set for five and a half hours because I
thought I'd get more work done because
at least pretty reliably you will find
that your quality of work is so much
worse proportionally that it does not
make up for the hours that you lost by
getting up early so or not getting up
early yeah do you ever meditate or
Journal no and I think that some of that
stuff is often over hyped as to its
impact but I also think that it's like
free and I think a lot of people do
benefit from it so I think if you're
somebody who finds benefit um and needs
to like reflect on things or needs to
calm down and that helps you calm down
by all means I don't think it's not
helpful I just don't feel it's uh I
don't like I I wouldn't want to do it
and I don't do it some people notice big
benefit from it though you know I notice
a good benefit from journaling because a
lot of the times if I'm struggling
through some sort of an issue I start
just writing and it just kind of tracks
what my mind is is thinking at a given
moment and then it always starts out
really negative but by the end of the
journaling session it turns out very
positive and I don't know what it is but
like I feel like you automatically want
to spin things in a positive way and it
is only how you let it affect yourself
so if you let it affect yourself in a
positive way it becomes a positive thing
so that's where I found the benefit in
journaling is just that yeah I think if
anything is actually impacting your
ability to perceive situations and like
emotionally respond in a more favorable
way and it only took you like sitting
down and writing about it for 15 minutes
or something like do that do that for
sure some people like think about stuff
in the shower some people think about it
while they're walking some people talk
to their significant other like people
have their own ways of working through
stuff and just because somebody doesn't
do it who you respect it doesn't mean
it's not valuable so I'm sure there's
lots of people that do and don't Journal
who are like successful or whatever
let's switch let's talk about prime
hydration Logan Paul called you a virgin
so you're responded with a threeh hour
video yeah what situations do you think
that Prime would be good yeah I think
that uh if you
are um somebody who wants something that
is artificially sweeten and tastes very
good to enhance your fluid intake cuz
some people just don't drink enough
water at that point I would say the
whatever potential negatives come from
artificial sweeteners which are very
speculative and not really founded by
literature and humans if you're
literally not going to drink water to a
degree that it's impactful on your
health in a negative way but you will
drink that much fluid with the stuff
that's like super sweet whatever
especially if you have a kid and he's
just refusing to hydrate properly
then yeah that could be helpful because
a lot of those like it's kind of wild to
me because despite them getting older
like Logan and KSI are like almost 30 or
30 their fan base seems to stay around
the same demographic almost like it just
Matthew mccon he gets older but they
stay the same age L yeah literally I do
think that some of those children may
like I've heard of insane examples where
kids will literally if they don't want
to eat what their parents have for them
that they deemed as healthy they'll just
like not eat or they'll do things that
are I don't know like they will avoid
drinking enough water because they just
don't like to taste of water doesn't
taste good so if the only way it's going
to get them to hydrate is by drinking
this stuff like could be could be
worthwhile um other than that though
it's like or if they're potassium
deficient which is some people are in
their diets could be helpful too A lot
of people have sodium Rich diets that
are aren't exercising regularly and
aren't sweating a lot and don't need
more sodium in a hydration drink so
those individuals if you're going to
like pound an electrolyte formula which
you probably didn't even need to begin
with like that's where a potassium rich
one might be a better choice than one
with a bunch of sodium in it because
you're already like fully topped out on
sodium you don't need anymore but a lot
of people are not hitting their
potassium needs so pottassium and
magnesium magnesium are the two minerals
that most people if you're were going to
like concentrate on which ones most
people are not getting enough of it's
those two however when you're marketing
it to like adult athletes who are
sweating and like cutting weight and
doing intensive competition as like the
right rehydration formula of
professional sports and like football
clubs and UFC fighters like that's where
it's like such a misalignment of utility
because it's like I guess I see it more
so as like a a Sweet Water replacement
like when I see Prime I don't think of
you know endurance athletes I'm just
thinking oh there's someone who's going
to pick this up because they like the
taste of it I think that's what they
love people to think though is that they
get the upside of like aligning with top
athletes in sports that they want to be
respected in but also get the sales
velocity from like the actual children
who buy the stuff so it's like this
weird paradoxical marketing misalignment
where it's like all of their sponsored
people are like adults at performing at
a high level in sport that would never
drink this but then all of their
customers are like little kids it's
really weird you know the breakdown of
their customer
if it's actually kids or if it's more
adults that are buying this I'd be very
curious to see yeah I think the demo is
mostly kids and they that's with data
that I've been given from like retail
stores too being somebody who like sells
retail stuff and how do they
differentiate between an adult buying it
for their child versus someone under the
age of 18 buying it that's a good
question um as far as like actually
getting hypers specific on how they
would calculate these things or like
gender or anything of that nature
I don't know how they do it I just know
that like when I see their audience as
well given the anecdotes I've been given
in the retail space given the audiences
I see show up to their events when they
do the events for Prime given like all
the circumstantial evidence that is
provided it looks to be dominated by
young children all of the anecdotes
about you know like super thrilled
customers even the thing he used as
proof that his product's great when he
called me a virgin he was like some
little kid so it's like there's not a
lot of people emailing in like I'm you
know an athlete in sport and this was
the thing that game was gamechanging for
me not that it needs to be but it's just
like I think proportionately more kids
are buying it I think adults drink it
because it tastes good too why don't you
create something that would be a
competition to that I have uh
electrolyte formula but it's not like
geared to their demographic so yeah and
I I just am like not that pushy about it
so I actually talked about at the end of
the three-hour video but it was very
brief got it yeah but um in general
again it's like two use cases are you
trying to have something that tastes
good and is widely adopted and people
slam all day that might make sense if
you're trying to just like drink
something that tastes good it's like
yeah like you said it could be like a
moo or like a water replacement sort of
thing right that said it has potassium
so you could actually give a misleading
representation of it like this has
electrolytes because it does it's not
inaccurate to say it's just not the
thing that you're primarily sweating out
when you're exercising and yet you're
marketing it through guys who are
literally weight cutting for the UFC
yeah it could be a good soda alternative
or if you're going to have like a Fanta
a l calorie as well it is I think it's
like 10 or 20 something calories 15
calories the way they market like if
they represented it in a fair way I
would be far less scrutinous of it it's
like the problem I have too is like I've
made videos reviewing company stuff and
like that's part of the content I made
back in the day was like supplement
reviews and stuff like that and like
there's a way to do it that is like a
more fair representation of what you're
seeing versus when him and KSI will
compare their product to others even the
other day they posted their energy drink
beside a Red Bull and they were like
Prime energy has 10 calories Red Bull
has 160 you would need to drink a Prime
energy this big to get the same amount
of calories as a Red Bull in K it's like
what it's this Giant drink and it's like
they completely intentionally Overlook
saying that Red Bull sugarfree is I
think less calories per can than theirs
and it's the exact makeup otherwise
other than being artificially sweetened
in zero calorie so like to basically
assert that this is their representation
of product they have a variant that is
what would be competitive with yours so
why are you completely overlooking it
entirely are there any illegalities of
putting your product next to somebody
else's and saying ours is better without
giving a full fair comparison in that
case I'm sure if they haven't been sued
yet I would assume no because they've
been doing it a lot it just seems like
even Mr Beast is is very careful about
how he positions Mr Beast bars against
Hershey's yeah like and never said he
never rarely ever says anything directly
it's usually which one do you like
better Mr Beast wins over her you know
yeah yeah that's the thing that's really
odd man because it's like Gatorade they
have how many different types of
Gatorade like six or seven different
variants and they all have different use
cases one of them is Gatorade zero which
has almost no calories and just tastes
good and is like a reasonable
electrolyte formula and yet Logan will
pick the one that has a ton of sugar in
it and is meant to be used in like very
specific use cases in sport and then
compare it to Prime which is meant to be
drank like in children who aren't even
exercising essentially be like ours has
10 calories theirs has look at this much
sugar this is how much sugar it is you
like pour it out in front of you it's
like dude
like I don't know it just kind screams
une ethical marketing to me it's just
not there's ways you could highlight the
utility of your product that don't
involve like misrepresenting your
competition so blatantly and it's like
the people that buy into it must be kids
cuz it's like you're literally marketing
to the lowest common denominator of like
understanding of what you're putting in
front of their face it's like oh more
sugar bad less sugar good in I think
most people are like that not just kids
I adults would see sugar no sugar just
automatically but an adult going to the
grocery store would they I guess maybe
they wouldn't look for like they
wouldn't even know the Gatorade product
exists cuz they heard Logan Paul say
that Gatorade equals bad
at which point it's questionable as to
like are you basically just
misrepresenting this other Brand's
offering because you're making it seem
like their entire catalog revolves
around this sugar dense like unhealthy
thing and yours is so dramatically
better and completely like steering
people away from the products that they
would actually buy from that company
should they know the truth so yeah I
know for me it it's so silly but when I
was a kid and maybe I was like 12 11
years old I went to the doctor's office
and they had this thing on the wall it
showed like you know a chocolate bar a
can of soda like all these things and
above it was the amount of sugar it had
in it in sugar cubes and when I saw the
can of soda and the amount of sugar that
was in it in Cube form that turned me
off from drinking soda as a kid so I
could see if you have this drink here
and you pour out the sugar it's it's
alarming to see how much sugar is put in
foods and drinks today that's true I
think the thing they lean on though
heavily is the fact that these companies
are so much bigger it's similar to like
a YouTuber doing a takedown video on you
and you trying to decide should I
respond to this or should I not is it
worth like giving them a platform is
what they said even valid you know you
consider all these things I'm sure
Gatorade and these other companies have
considered like this is complete
nonsense like do we do anything I guess
we can't because it's like this company
then if they respond then they're
bringing a lot of attention they can't
respond to exactly so like I think they
know this and they lean into it cuz when
you don't hear any push back a lot of
people will blindly believe it yeah and
then who's actually watching the adults
on YouTube who are dismantling the
videos and whatnot probably not little
kids like my demographic I can almost
guarantee is older than Logan's yeah I
don't know it's uh it's wild dude and um
yeah it's like I've never seen somebody
so committed to making as much money as
possible even to the detriment of
long-term brand credibility like the guy
often is synonymous with scammer now and
he doesn't even seem to care I've seen
some wild stuff that he's put out there
to monetize off his audience even to the
extent of putting like I wasn't even
aware he did another uh like nft thing
behind a pay wall for his members of his
membership site so imagine was that 99
Originals he's done multiple apparently
so he's done like uh 99 Originals crypto
zoo and then there was like a bunch of
others I wasn't even aware he did but
there was this one and I think it's
pretty egregious that you would do this
to your most DieHard people is you paid
for a pay wall to get exclusive content
CU you're such a fan of this guy and he
doesn't even really post there
apparently and then once you're behind
there you get pitched at nft that you
only have access to because you're like
one of the most committed fans and you
get rug pulled on that like holy [__]
dude like talk about slapping your
audience in the face what's interesting
is I remember when he was doing the
Pokemon box breaks the second one he did
uh he included an nft or he sold nfts of
the hollows he pulled like and at the
peak those nfts they all sold out the
first day but a lot of them were selling
for over
$40,000 40,000 for an nft of him pulling
a Charizard card yeah I'm so curious
what those would sell for today nothing
I've seen the values like nothing
they've actually crashed to nothingness
there's been assessments of this that
check the before and afters and like
what happened to those projects and
they're all worthless and he will never
talk about it think dink coin or
whatever all that [__] I always assume
that was a joke though dude I I never
you did but a lot of other people I
don't think anybody is taking that
serious I could be wrong but like I
don't think anyone look at Dink and well
people know that it's a nonsense thing
that's not meant to be a real business
in general but it's the fact that he's
like I'm putting my money into this and
it's stupid but it'll probably gain
value because shitcoins are blowing up
right now and I think it's Pro like has
good potential like you've endorsed it
yeah to your audience there's no way you
thought all those crypto projects were
going to go to the moon and like it's
all going to be fine and and then not be
apologetic after words for how they've
all crashed into nothingness sweep it
all under the rug try and like threaten
coffeezilla to sue him and then when he
actually doesn't back down all of a
sudden now you're like you care about
everyone yeah man like it's wild because
it's like it almost reinforces just
doing whatever you need to get ahead
it's wild like it's not a good story
necessarily for takeaways of motivation
in my opinion like every time you can
monetize off your audience milk the [__]
out of them like what he's done and it's
worked quite well at least from a
monetary perspective so I don't know I
feel like at some point it's like
there's going to be such an
overwhelmingly negative perspective of
what he's doing that maybe it muddles
out the rest but he's also done an
exceptional job of being viral in
moments that also mute out those
situations seemingly like replace the
audience with kids who don't know about
it and just keep recycling it yeah
there's going to be some random Youtube
channel with like 30,000 subscribers
that makes like a 6h hour expose video
on I think that's the one I I just saw
one the other day and it like literally
made a chronological timeline of every
scam he's done oh actually yeah I don't
know how viral is right now oh I think
I've seen that I think it was the I
think it was the channel King of Nothing
yeah oh King of Nothing right I've seen
him before I think I think that was the
it was a long he had a lot of stuff that
I didn't even know existed you know and
it was like oh man this guy's done like
like I don't know I I'd probably be Mis
quoting but it was like five plus rug
Bulls or something or like crypto hype
situations that you knew were nonsense
like things that weren't valid
businesses that you had no idea what was
going on and all you cared about was
hyping it up so you could make something
off of it hopefully so yeah dude it's uh
it's like I don't know like there's
examples of people doing it the right
way and there's people doing it the
wrong way and I think he's an example of
the wrong way personally like I don't
think it's you know admirable that he
has this oh billion dollar Prime like
yeah man congrats but like at the
expense of what do you think he's on
gear maybe certainly possible I think
that his uh he has great genetics for
sure so I think it's plausible it could
be natural but you know the drug testing
parameters of the last fight were pretty
suspect I think it was like testing at
competition only for example um and yeah
like with the type of training he's
doing boxing and he's still like gaining
size seemingly I don't know like it's uh
it's a tossup for sure I would say I
could go go either way so I wouldn't
definitively say I know for sure how how
are peptides different basically
steroids bind to a certain receptor
called the Androgen receptor it was the
thing I talked about where how you
respond to hormones could dictate you
know how much you respond regardless of
how much is present with peptides they
are typically more
Rehabilitation oriented and more like
Pro uh recovery they do a lot of
different things because you could find
examples of peptides that literally I
don't know if you guys have heard Milano
tan 2o before dude if you pull this up
you will find some wild people are about
to be like mind blown if they' never
heard of it you can literally inject
this stuff stimulate the production of
melanin in somebody who literally cannot
tan at all even an albino person and
make them black if you want to what yeah
so there's some people who change their
race manually with this peptide so you
could do it for like six months yeah and
there and change back yeah there was
some woman I made a video on who not
only made herself black but then went on
like national news and was asserting she
is like actually African-American and
had like was always like that or
something so she was actually asserting
her like that was her background too and
um yeah a lot of people use it to stay
tan year round and it's pretty good at
it is there any negative side effects
I'm really pale that's uh I would love
to get a little bit more color on my SK
it was never FDA approved so you have to
buy it on the Underground essentially
and and it will one of the negatives is
it like flushes your skin for like an
hour so you get like a really red face
which is kind of unsightly it'll also
Raise Your Heart Lake a little bit
seemingly but um you could also get
moles and freckles in areas that maybe
you didn't want them permanently it
seems to kind of go away when your T
goes away too um one of the side effects
interestingly enough is spontaneous
erections so people get it they actually
the developers of the drug realized it
was doing that and they like pulled out
the like I don't know afrodesiac SL like
sexual enhancing characteristics of it
and made a female libido drug out of it
and it's actually FDA approved for
female uh like lack of female liido oh
wow yeah so that this drug exists it's
called VII I believe and you can get it
prescribed as a woman for low drive and
yeah it doesn't tan you as much but it
just makes you hornier um there's some
other ones there's a lot of other ones
that all do varying things like ones
that enhance
like uh tissue repair for example and or
like Pro um like blood vessel formation
could help get like actual circulation
to areas and injuries that otherwise
would have been like pretty difficult to
get uh blood flow to um there's array of
different ones um it's amazing they have
the technology to do something like that
yeah there's like to me it seems like
magic there's this one called
ghrp6 and it stimulates the receptor
that makes you hungry so you could use
it and literally like Crush an eating
competition what about physical
limitations like your stomach size even
if you're not hungry it will make you
hungry like it overrides signals do all
you can eat sushi that's what we got to
do horrible I $300 Sushi what situations
would you want to just be perpetually
hungry well that's the thing it's not
Perpetual you can like it's in and out
of your system relatively quickly so you
could I know but to overeat like that
you would think that your stomach might
eventually burst or like there's risks
to that at some point like you get full
but in enhances Your Capacity to like
override satiation mechanism essentially
so a me with bodybuilders though a lot
of times the bottleneck of gaining size
is food intake so for them it's
worthwhile potentially for you not so
much for you maybe I don't know sounds
like it might be but like back in the
day too people were doing I almost did
this I'm glad I didn't but 10,000
calorie eating challenges were really
big in Fitness YouTube back in the day I
was like everyone's getting this is
before I had a big Channel I was like
everyone's getting viral videos of
10,000 calorie challenge I'm going to do
the 10,000 calorie in one meal challenge
like in less than an hour and I was
going to do it and I decided not to but
that was what I would have used if I
wanted to do it so this sounds stupid
okay yeah uh 3500 calories is 1 pound of
of fat yep if you eat 10,000 calories
does that and and your Baseline let's
just say is 2,000 does that
automatically mean that you're going to
gain almost three PB or sorry 2 lb uh um
I I would be like is there a limit to
how many calories your body could absorb
in a day probably I would think there'd
be some level of like malabsorption
happening I don't know to what what
degree that's a really interesting
question though maybe that's a hack is
like you have to eat 15,000 calories in
a day and his last 10,000 calories don't
count and then like don't eat the rest
of the week yeah basically that's yeah
that's uh wildly enough and this shows
how bad the eating habits are in the
fitness industry is one of the ways that
I used to eat and a lot of people still
eat is you have perfect discipline from
Monday to Saturday or whatever days you
decide and then on the seventh day you
just go ham and you just eat whatever if
you're actually really lean and dieted
down it's pretty easy to crush like
10,000 calories of just anything and
after that you've kind of like made
yourself sick to the point that food
isn't that appealing and the next three
days or so you kind of get back to what
you were at and then you start making
progress again and it's kind of the
cycle of uh you know binging and then
dep driving yourself and binging it and
it's not sustainable so that's where I
wouldn't recommend that gosh what about
the liver King diet the one that he
doesn't even follow himself because he
has a different one how do you get
access to all this information he tried
to hire me as a coach before he was
online so like he sent me some like
pretty like damning information from his
uh official company email and I didn't
realize it at the time and then he like
went on to basically abuse hormones and
compounds to build a bigger than life
like social media presence and obviously
he got big very fast and then previous
to that anyone who knew what he was
actually doing and lying about had that
information and he just didn't think it
was risk or risky enough I guess why did
you decide to make that information
public and what was going through your
mind at the time yeah so with him it was
kind of interesting because I didn't
even know I had it for a while I was
just kind of like I made speculative
videos on it because he's basically
telling people he's natural I'm like
there's no [__] way this guy's
natural so I'd made a couple videos just
objectively looking at what I could tell
and G giving my opinion and I just saw
him going on a rampage of lying on
podcasts to people's faces and it even
got to the extent where he was telling
people that you're like sub Primal if
you're on hormones like you're like a
lesser man essentially which there's a
lot of people that literally need them
to thrive or function um he was saying
things like you're pathetic if you think
I am
um that just shows how bad of work ethic
you have how could you not think this is
achievable if I actually took steroids
then you'd see what it would look like
maybe I will just to shut you idiots up
just like wild stuff I was like dude and
then the monetary upside was kind of
hard to ignore that he was asserting
that what he was doing was so conducive
to his progress and whatnot that it's
not like he attributed that you could
get his physique to his diet or his
supplements but it was like that was the
takeaway a lot of people were getting is
like your ancestral consistent he was
like telling Hanan on a H3 podcast like
you shouldn't take trt just do the
ancestral disciplines and then you will
be able to double your testosterone
levels like I have you know like a lot
of his message is Noble in practice and
overall the takeaways are good but it
was getting to the extent where he was
actually um very clearly biased in order
to promote it in such a way that he was
doing everything ancestrally consistent
and it equals the outcome he has when in
reality he was lying and taking hormones
to achieve it and you know like there's
a myriad of ethical complications that
come into your own judgment if it's like
fair or not so for me it was kind of
like sick of seeing this guy just like
going on a rampage on social media I was
like you know what like you're not going
to tell the truth so I'll tell it for
you would there be a situation where you
would reach out to him first and say hey
I have this information well the thing
is he knew I had it cuz he sent it to me
maybe he forgot I mean dude he he knew I
guess he just like wouldn't you go to
him first and say hey I got this
information you know I have it I want to
make this video cuz you're making these
claims I'll give you the opportunity to
say it first from your channel and if
you don't then I will make my video but
I'd like you to have the opportunity did
that ever cross your mind or was that
ever an option or yeah like I suppose
that that is something that could have
been done but I felt like he had more
than enough opportunity he'd been
presented with the question a zillion
times and basically spit in people's
faces when he asked it it and there was
a point when he was also like not
responding to me on social media and I
was like I don't really care to engage
with the guy necessarily so you know I
just didn't see it worthwhile at the
time too so the guy's going to continue
to lie like to my friends faces too like
he'd go on podcast with people I'm I
respect and I'm friends with and just be
like you know uh dodgy lying saying
complete misrepresentations of what he's
doing and um I don't know especially
like the this you know saying you don't
need blood work too and like you're sub
Primal if you think you you know I
should have blood work and cholesterol
levels are like he was saying a lot of
nonsense and it was like over the top to
where I don't know like I felt like he
had two years to come clean or whatever
it was and he just wasn't going to do it
and he was getting leaning harder and
harder into it and I was like yeah man
like you know I have this too like you
sent it to me so obviously you either
think I'm like too scared to come out
with it or like don't care if I do or or
I don't know don't think I'm going to I
don't know did you get any backlash from
that video yeah a little bit yeah and
what was the criticism you got on that
well similar to the you know ethical
conundrum you just present presented
it's like how do you like you know make
sense of making that versus opposite
other options and um yeah it's certainly
an interesting question but um yeah it
was uh I think ultimately people were
just happy to see the truth come out and
then him finally admit it and then see
how he responded to it and what he would
say cuz all of a sudden after that point
like I think that hormones have a viable
you know are viable for people who need
them and I'm going to you know try and
go natural and then he ends up going
back on hormones again he self-
admittedly on hormones again now so what
happened when he went off of steroids
who knows if he did dude he said he did
I didn't see any blood work proof so I
don't know maybe he tried and um I'm
sure that the biggest thing he probably
had a hurdle getting over is the fact
that even if you come off if you've like
subjected yourself to this level of
exposure for however long there's no
guarantee you're going to like get back
to high functioning status naturally
necessarily even if everything's perfect
so it almost begs the question like how
impactful is this ancestral living that
is supposedly so optimal for everything
and correcting hormones when you
yourself with every like Avenue and
means and resources of an ancestrally
consistent person can't even restore
your hor hormones after coming
off like it doesn't look too good so I'm
sure there was like a lot of different
you know thoughts that went into like
how he should handle it what should he
do what should I say I'm doing should I
say I'm coming off what I'm probably
planning on staying on like what am I
going to do about it so I don't know and
like ultimately he's the only one who
knows for sure what he did but to me and
objectively everyone else kind of
watching doesn't look like he really
changed a whole lot in recent I'm sure
he like isn't abusing the hell out of
some of the growth hormone dosages he
was now but some of it is uh yeah man I
don't know like he wasin definitely
lying everyone and now the truth's out
and he's uh handled as well as he could
I guess yeah is there anything left that
you haven't said to him that you want to
say no not really dude no no he like
asked me to be in some documentary thing
and I was like I don't really see the
point personally like I think we've kind
of like beat this horse to death and
people know and like you've said that I
don't I don't necessarily think he's
coming from the best place of like I I
don't trust him necessarily so I'm very
hesitant to like be like you know you
have the best intentions was what ever
you're doing at this point forward so I
should just associate with you like
certainly not my thought process so um
yeah it's uh it's interesting to see
what he's doing though because again
like I think his overall message is
Noble you know some of the stuff that
he's seen with his kids getting better
from autoimmune issues like that's real
stuff that is worth taking note of and
it sucks that it overshadows it may be
overshadowed by this thing but like it
was kind of his brought it upon himself
to kind of like co-mingle the two you
could have easily been like yeah like
I'm on hormone replacement therapy but
like these are the lifestyle practices I
utilize and I think even people who are
natural should utilize to optimize
health and here's why and like Paul
saladino he's huge now and he does not
you not have to lean into some fake
natural physique and like lie to his
fanss or anything about it so I'm not
saying he's like perfect either because
he definitely makes some pretty like you
know aggressive claims sometimes about
like vegetables and whatnot but like
he's certainly not lying about being on
like $20,000 of gear to his and then
selling the product so yeah yeah it's
really interesting because I I look at
Paul saladino's diet and it seems so
counterintuitive and so anti-food
pyramid which I know is kind of a people
will say it's a scam everything's a scam
the food pyramid is a scam but I tried
Paul saladino's diet which diet though
CU he CH he's changed his stance I would
say it's the more recent one so I went
out I bought raw honey I bought
non-pasteurized uh like milk uh cheese
uh I just did 80 D20 ground beef I
bought uh beef Tallow oh sorry grass-fed
grass finished ground beef which is key
I bought beef Tallow I did the whole
nine yards and I would eat like two meat
patties with the non-pasteurized dairy
and then put a glob of raw honey on it
and it and maybe a organic banana on the
side sure sure and it was really good
but as I'm eating it I'm thinking to
myself there's no way that this is
healthy you know what I mean like he
says he's MD right and he says it's
super healthy and I had that meal day
after day after day after day yeah and
there's just no way if I'm looking at
that plate that it's healthy yeah dude
it's uh it's interesting for sure
because I think again similar to what we
talked about about how if you're in a
deficit doesn't matter what you're
eating like you can lose weight eating
garbage not not that I'm saying what
he's doing is garbage but you can lose
weight essentially eating anything it's
just how you lose the weight and what it
results in from like a signaling aspect
a muscle retention standpoint cognitive
Health like some of these things will
vary but you will reliably lose weight
regardless of what you're eating if it's
McDonald's if it's Burgers whatever on
it Etc so with him a lot of The Upside I
would say is ultimately that his energy
balance is good regardless so as long as
you're in like a sustainable model where
you're not overeating like that's the
majority of your benefit from the lwh
hanging fruit stuff so like he is
surfing daily he's exercising regularly
he's metabolically fit and he's doing
things to sustain it it's not just like
he's eating what would be considered
perfectly he's also not overeating it so
to actually say oh is this you know the
sugar and stuff good with the meat like
it very much depends on what you're
doing activity wise like if you're just
sedentary I'm sure he would not be
telling you like slam a bunch of you
know honey and sugar and this and that
too like it very much depends on what
you are exposing yourself to um but
again I'm not like a nutrition expert I
don't claim to be I certainly don't like
that field either there's a lot of like
dogma and like controversial takes in it
and um I think that he does uh
potentially downplay the importance of
certain lipid parameters that are like
pretty reliably shown to be
atherosclerosis concerning for sure and
his assertion is that if you're
metabolically healthy it doesn't really
matter what your LDL cholesterol is or
these numbers and it's like resulted in
Endless debates between him and like
Lane Norton who responds to his stuff
and just like dunks on him constantly
and then people who are on his side who
say how great they feel too which is a
real thing that's not to say that's not
real but um to say what's optimal versus
not it like depends on your genetics
depends on your blood work depends on
how you respond to the food itself and
um yeah like a lot of the stuff he eats
it's on the basis of it being nutrient
rich and bioavailable and unlikely to
cause autoimmune issues and like it's
hard to argue with that logic when you
just stop there when you get above and
beyond that like okay is this much sugar
good for what I'm doing is it
sustainable how difficult is it to even
procure these things because a lot of
people are like I'm sure you had like a
pretty arduous process very hard to find
beef Tallow and relatively expensive it
was very expensive yeah how much was it
I it
probably I mean 8020 grass-fed grass
finished ground beef is about twice as
expensive per pound as just like any
other type
and everything else is basically two to
two and half times more expensive and I
had to go to Sprouts you know you can't
go to like Alberton or Ralphs or
something like I absolutely don't want
the takeaway from that to be don't eat
good because it's expensive because like
I think if anything you should spend
good money on is food I agree however I
think a lot of what he says has validity
but I also think he uh leans a little
bit to in the scare like fearmonger side
of diet and he will extrapolate out from
like rodent literature stuff that might
not actually be super replicable to
humans and then say see like you know
soy [__] up this rat so don't like
ever eat this or whatever like and then
he kind of like invites scrutiny by
trying to like seemingly have like a bit
of a I don't know myopic view around
trying to like I don't know it's kind of
like it's not it's not liver King at all
but like he's definitely lean to the
viral angle a bit which I don't think he
needs to he's a super intelligent guy
who people respect his opinion he
doesn't need to do that kind of stuff so
at the end of the day his diet model
works for him it works great seemingly
he gets regular uh Imaging to make sure
he doesn't have atherosclerosis
accumulating at least that's what he
says and um you know I don't know like
if you're hitting your micronutrients
and your Macros you're not gaining
weight and you like it like I guess part
of the hangup is do you even like this
food because a lot of people are just
not going to like that stuff I tried his
like raw milk like honey concoction the
other dayed yeah he made one for me I
[__] hated it I actually didn't mind
it raw milk and and non-pasteurized
honey but again that's just like so is
it realistic for for me to eat like
that's a lot of calories too the raw
milk presumably yeah plus the honey
which is like a sugar bomb
essentially is the most satiating thing
I could be allocating like 400 or
whatever calories to this like drink
probably not dude so I'm not going to
argue with the validity of its
micronutrient density and the quality of
the food but like perhaps it's not the
most conducive thing to like my ideal
diet so I don't think everyone should
copy what he does I don't think he would
assert in like a long form podcast
either that everyone should copy him to
the the money either he said that before
he says everybody responds differently
and he thinks as a general rule of thumb
like broad Strokes that this is a pretty
good diet for yeah I think in general if
you choose from the food groups that he
has asserted as good quality stuff like
it's hard to go wrong pending that
you're also doing other things right
because a lot of people don't exercise
and they don't sleep well and they don't
do these other things to the real
argument comes into the propensity to
atherosclerosis and if you can avoid it
entirely just by being metabolically fit
which is super super questionable but he
will tell you pretty aggressively if you
are metabolically healthy like don't
worry about it if you follow this diet
exercise Etc like that's where it gets
really finicky because there are people
that seemingly end up with clogged
arteries regardless of how metabolically
fit they are and then he'll assert that
that date is nonsense and then it's like
this endless argument where you're not
able to like prove one way or the
other but from what I've seen I think
you should be a bit cautious with I
think there's absolutely a balance take
where don't just blindly assume that
you're going to be covered cuz you're
eating a car for diet we should have
Paul on the podcast I'd be down it would
make a really interesting we could we
could even go to him he's in Puerto Rico
right or something like that yeah yeah
he was just uh I don't know when he's
going to be traveling next because I
know he was just in Arizona and then he
was just in Austin to meet up with me
and then now he's in Puerto Rico or
Costa Rica Costa Rica is that yeah yeah
um yeah but I'm sure he'd be down man
like yeah could be a fun trip I would
love to go to Costa Rica that would be
amazing yeah yeah I feel like most
people's diets are just so bad so if you
take his diet anything is an improvement
yeah it's just going to be better than
you know eating Doritos chips I think
what a lot of the thing because again
I'm not again A nutrition content
creator necessarily so I don't have like
extreme bias towards one way or the
other I just want to eat what makes me
feel the best perform the best and the
least chance of dying like that is
essentially what I care about so
whatever gets me there like I don't
really care what it is as long as I like
it too and sustainable and I'm not going
to e and get fat on it with them though
they get like really granular about like
proving each other are insane almost to
the point that it's like it's uh it's
hard to really like realize that a lot
of the intelligent people on both sides
of the camps are saying a lot of the
same things and they act like it's
totally different like just because Paul
said don't eat oatmeal it doesn't mean
this other guy saying don't eat red meat
or something like a lot of people assert
that there it's like vegetarian versus
carnivore but often times the the people
that Paul is actually arguing with at
least from like the educated side of
this equation are people who are like
actually eating red meat regularly and
have high quality you know Stakes on a
daily basis and are doing the right
lifestyle practices and this and that
there's just the one disagreement that I
see that has not been fully fleshed out
where like everyone's in agreement on is
how problematic is it to have elevated
um
atherogenic lipoproteins which is
essentially like your your cholesterol
profile like at a granular level is
there a possibility to end up with heart
disease even if you're eating the
perfect animal-based carnivore based
diet with the surfing with the with
everything and this is assuming that
it's in a regular person too because
obviously not everyone is Paul with the
perfect lifestyle and all the resources
to get like insanely high quality food
and like whatever so considerations have
to be made and it was perhaps a super
long ramble but like I think what he
says has validity for sure and I think a
lot of the food choices he has are you
know questionably sustainable for some
people and questionably affordable but
also like you know they're still high
quality there's no arguing there I loved
the diet it's like my favorite foods to
eat believe it or not like honey Globs
of Honey on top of raw me or not raw
meat on top of like 8020 ground beef is
like it's it's incredible yeah uh but it
just looks like it's just I'm just
injecting it looks like I'm injecting my
arteries with like cholesterol when I'm
doing that it looks like if you saw a
picture at the doctor's office of like
what not yeah what not it's that but I'm
like I feel good but it just everyone
that would see it would be like what are
you eating yeah you know no totally
understandable I can see way people
would think that too do you take
creatine yes and I would highly
recommend it for almost everyone even
women and there is new literature
emerging on how impactful it is on brain
health fertility metrics and other
things aside from just muscle now this
makes me want to make another comment
cuz I started taking creatine now I play
pickle ball I play recreationally but
I'm very serious when I went and I
started taking creatine I noticed I got
a lot heavier and I just felt heavy on
my feet and I checked it with my other
friend who skateboards and he's like
yeah I could Allie like six inches lower
that was like my Max oi height when I
was taking creatine because you just get
so heavy so quickly and you feel slower
and bogged down and your arms yeah sure
they get bigger and you feel stronger
and you can push more weight in the gym
but it just slows you down so one thing
you have to consider too is in sports
when you go watch an Olympic events or
Olympics in general there is different
categories of even like Runners check
the body types of guys in the 100 meter
200 400 800 it's like reliably you will
see a decrease in muscle mass of like
double digit pounds almost M just
because the guy at the 100 meter has
more muscle it doesn't mean he's going
to perform as well in an endurance event
as the really skinny guy in like the
whatever so to use that as a negative
against creatine is certainly not fair
like it's not Apples to Apples where
it's like okay for skateboarding we're
being lighter on your feet
proportionally is more advantageous
potentially than whatever upside you get
out of it like okay in that circumstance
how important is skateboarding to
relative to whatever benefits you get
out of this like if alling higher and
not getting creatin upside is like you
know your determination of more useful
then don't take it so it is pro health
as well as Pro muscular performance but
in certain context like yeah maybe more
not harmful but like less helpful for
like specific Sports interesting okay I
was concerned that that was like just
overall bad for my health cuz when I
feel slower on my feet and I feel like
I'm just not as agile I'm just like okay
that's just a metric of like this is
something I should stop doing but I
suppose if there's like brain function
advantages and other things as well and
then obviously pushing more weight in
the gym looking stronger feeling
stronger those could outweigh it what
are your thoughts on
ag1 yeah I uh think that it is of the
available greens formulas probably the
most rigorously or at least at least
what I'm aware of like I think I've had
like 50 plus iterations they've
sponsored my channel before and I think
in general green formulas it's very
difficult to get an amount that is even
something people would drink into a
powder because it would be almost
disgusting if you were to get like tons
of greens into a powdered format so I
think the limitation is more on the
taste
profile as opposed to like the formula's
validity CU I think that the people
behind it are really good people who
actually like go out of their way to do
good sourcing of ingredients are pretty
mindful of like reflecting current
literature everyone I know and trust
speaks very highly of them like huberman
speaks very highly of them Atia Etc like
these are guys that I defer to for my
own education so if I was to say a
greens formula that exists I would be I
would trust them more than most
companies that said do I think that it's
going to replace Greens in your diet no
I think it's a supplement at best also
do I think that you're going to get like
a super effective amount of every
ingredient that's in the formula
definitely not there's like I don't know
dozens of ingredients that are there
some of them objectively perhaps to like
look good on the label not in impactful
amounts but I think also this is just
sort of the standard for the greens
industry so you can only put so much
before people won't drink it and there's
definitely some you know consideration
of that as well so you know if I was to
look at green formulas that exist from
what I'm aware of there like one of the
better ones we had a guest on our
podcast Justin Waller and he said that
when he works out his abs he only works
out the bottom two what are your
thoughts on that um why did he say that
because you don't see people walking
around with only the bottom two ABS
usually the people have the top two or
the top four and a real six-pack of ABS
needs the bottom two so if he works out
the bottom two realistically it's just
the top four are going to follow suit
did you ask him about spot reduction cuz
like I would be wondering
like if I'm trying to develop a balanced
core I am trying to Target the whole
thing I don't want to have like a
underdeveloped stability in the top four
rather than and just the bottom two like
that's how you would end up with
injuries typically I don't even know how
you would really work just the bottom
two like there's definitely waste the
target we have a clip that went really
viral show them the clip I don't know if
I can let me see if I can find it
there's no it I think it's one of our
most viewed YouTube there's definitely
ways to Target proportionally more down
there but like okay right here found out
16 million views on Instagram there you
go that's crazy I've had a sixpack since
I was 24 years old when I do abs I only
do the bottom two ABS how many guys have
you met like oh I got the top two my
[__] Grandma's got the top two get your
ribs ass I only have the top exactly
come on exactly but if you do
decline weighted abs like with a 45 on
your chest and you only focus on the
bottom two and you tote your head back
so you isolate it no nobody in history
of the universe has ever had the bottom
two in this V taper and not have the top
two you ever do a side plank yeah okay
cool go up and put your hand on them
make sure it burns and when it finally
starts to burn
bounce pul on that [__] it up
fight fight want to destroy it I used to
do that two minutes A Time on each side
you kind of get that 300 look I'm
telling you you'll have a sixpack faster
than you would anyway I try that it's an
absolute Che it pokes through the skin
why I just he wasn't convincing enough
just going in the history of the
universe ja probably realistically I
probably just forgot it okay so like
it's to me the stuff he says is not like
inaccurate that that when would you see
a guy with the bottom to not the top
it's like well like yeah cuz that's
where that accumulates so you probably
wouldn't have got abs anywhere if you
weren't lean enough so like what he says
it's like that's true I guess I wouldn't
but like it's I don't know like to me
it's implying there's some sort of like
localized fat reduction that you could
get out of that exercise or you're going
to end up with underdeveloped lower abs
relative to the others that is not
related to diet whatsoever so it's like
I do think that that's like a viable
exercise I just don't think it has the
importance that he implies because at
the end of the day abs are made in the
kitchen I don't think he would deny that
I think isn't didn't he say he eats like
once a day or something yeah so it's
like you know like it's his diet that is
conducive mostly to the ABS so I would
be shocked to see the difference in him
having body fat vers not is like the
thing that's going to make the biggest
difference if you're training your abs
if you want to hit the lower ones like I
know people who don't train ABS at all
and have better looking ABS than anyone
I've ever seen and they train it
indirectly through core stabilizing
exercises that are compound movements I
don't necessarily think you like need to
do them or don't do them it could be
useful if you want to have like a good
core that is proportionally strong to
the rest of your body but doing the
exercise to get the ABS is like it's
made in the kitchen at the end of the
day so like I don't think there's any
localized fat reduction I don't think it
makes that big of a difference on the
development of them where it's going to
look way different like I think it's
kind of exaggerated think it sounds like
something you would hear like I don't
know it's like a like a broth sort of
thing yeah and not to speak poorly about
his advice either like obviously the guy
is in good shape and whatever but it's
like I can almost guarantee like 99% of
it comes from his diet yeah all right
all right I don't think there's anything
else left yeah is there anything that
you wanted to talk about anything you
want to bring up I don't know like what
what do you guys spend the majority of
your time on now that you feel is
worthwhile in the biggest Roi for the
podcast it would be travel us finding
the time to go to our guests let's just
say like like in your week though like
what do you have of all of your trials
and tribulations of having multiple
channels reaction videos doing your like
very targeted Main Channel videos
podcasts like what do you feel like is
the most valuable use of your time now
honestly it's posting less is it's weird
as that sounds it's posting Less on the
main Channel I was posting three times a
week and I did that for six and a half
years and it wasn't until I think two
months ago give or take I started
posting once a week and the views have
gone up since I posted once a week
overall overall okay yeah uh doing
shorts is fantastic as as far as my own
time I'm I think I'm focusing more time
on myself which I've never done before
nice dude yeah like pain pain in the
garage was a big one I spent three days
painting the garage I love doing that um
I got a blank canvas want to do some art
that's so random but uh give that a shot
nice dude uh and Home Improvement stuff
been getting really into that I did my
backyard lights uh in La did it myself
and it's super easy to do you buy all
the equipment online it's really easy
you don't need like an electrician or I
paid some dude 600 bucks I just watched
how he did it on the side of the house
and I thought I could do that and I did
H easy nice for a fifth of the cost when
it comes to stuff like that content like
obviously on the surface you saying less
content are you proportionally doing
more elsewhere that makes you or are you
better at like managing your not going
insane while you're not working uh no
I'm spending longer on each video but
just because I have more time not
because I'm actually spending more time
on the video it's just it's the work is
expanding because I have more time
available to me that's really it um but
now in the videos itself I got that down
a science I mean I know the structure I
know what does well I know which topics
I could talk about it it just flows you
didn't upake your output of podcast
frequency or anything though we we tried
we tried two a week uh for a little bit
and we discovered it didn't work uh one
a week was a sweet spot I think
especially for a three-hour episode yeah
uh people doing that twice a is just too
much so we could throw in like a midweek
every now and then but we found once a
week is the perfect amount and then we
could do shorts in between so as odd as
it seems I think working less is uh to
our benefit at this point how many
people do you have on the team now for
like editors people who clip stuff
whatever so it's Graham and I as the
host we have a producer that does a lot
of the editing talking to Brands stuff
like that just behind the scenes stuff
we just hired him too so we're kind of
training him we have our shortform
editor that Clips up things for vertical
content Tik Tok uh Instagram YouTube
shorts and that that guy has his own
agency we're just one of his clients we
have an agency that repurposes our
content to a Snapchat tile so we have
that and they also do it for Facebook so
we also that's the same agency there and
then we have a few different random
agencies and agents that we work with to
Source brand
deals I appreciate the Insight man yeah
appreciate you guys having me to thank
you so much for coming on man I really
appreciate it I love this and we'll link
to all of your information down below in
the description so anyone who wants to
check you out description thank you
appreciate thanks awesome
cool